Gaspard Proust
[Applaudissements]
alors oui avant de présenter mes vœux
pour 2013 j'ai une pensée émue pour tous
les Syriens qui se sont souhaités une
bonne santé et qui n'ont peut-être pas
eu le temps de finir cette phrase
d'ailleurs je me demande mais cette
année pour la France c'est pas des vœux
qu'il faudrait présenter mais des
prières
alors tout le monde dit que 2013 sera
plus dur que 2012 ah bon c'est possible
mais non enfin c'est une bonne année aux
pauvres en 2013 qu'il se rassure ils
vont se sentir de moins en moins seul et
c'est toujours moins dur comme ça
la pauvreté c'est comme la chaude pisse
en garnison quand t'es seul ta honte
quand tes 10 tu la compare avec celle
des autres voilà
[Applaudissements]
faut positiver donc 2013 l'année de la
transition des emplois de l'industrie
versus des services c'est quand même pas
rien sortir de la mine pour aller à
l'ANPE
quitter la lampe frontale pour le néon
de Pôle emploi c'est il a unepe c'est
qu'une étape avant le RSA les restos du
cœur Emmaüs Jean-Marc Morandini
et vraiment au pire il y a l'amendicité
mais la mendicité c'est quoi c'est c'est
du théâtre de rue avec une mise en scène
minimaliste c'est vrai qu'il se passe
pas grand chose mais au moins il y a une
vraie transparence sur les subventions
en 2013 de toute façon j'ai décidé de me
calmer je ne vais plus du tout taper sur
l'exécutif du pont et Dupont c'est fini
je ne héros Hollande et je peux plus
rien alors c'est vrai que c'est
peut-être pas des flèches mais pour une
fois que dans ce pays on a le choix
entre deux noms pour appeler le soldat
inconnu
et dans la foulée j'aimerais présenter
mes vœux au 75% qui passeront l'hiver ah
oui ça je suis sûr on aura bien les 75%
jusqu'à la fin du quinquennat sauf que
ça va pas concerner le taux d'imposition
mais le chiffre du chômage alors comme
quoi chez les socialistes si on a
l'intuition du chiffre on n'a pas
forcément la certitude de son objet
[Rires]
en tout cas je souhaite une bonne année
au Conseil constitutionnel qui est
devenu le centre de planning familial du
PS c'est là où se font avorter toutes
les lois socialistes
on n'imaginait pas les membres les sages
en avorteur enfin bon c'est comme ça
c'est la vie tout arrive alors je vous
passe les détails ce qui arrivera dans
quatre ans à tout le monde le sait
réélection de Sarko au premier tour
momification de lien de Bettencourt
ouverture de son mausolée place de la
Concorde alors ce sera évidemment une
catastrophe pour le cinéma français je
veux dire même si Depardieu va revenir
vu sa grande moralité t'aurait-on va
sans doute quitter la France et prendre
un passeport en nord-coréen
tout le monde sait ce qui arrive si tu
aurais ton quitte la France enfin il y a
plus un film qui va se monter
pardon
2013 comment ça c'est bien pour les
salariés de Virgin oui ils vont pouvoir
partir au ski avant les autres
parce que chez Virgin et oui on solde
aussi les employés alors bon forcément
je me suis précipité quoi j'ai déjà
repéré une vendeuse pas mal enfin c'est
c'est mon côté salafiste athée quoi
c'est dans un magasin qui s'appelle
Virgin et son forcément toutes de
première main
évidemment tout le monde c'est un digne
que Virgin dépose le bilan enfin ça va
il était temps quoi ils vendent des CD
des DVD enfin pourquoi pas des Minitel
et des machines à écrire enfin c'est en
fait Virgin Megastore ce n'était pas un
magasin mais un musée des succès du 20e
siècle
ça fait scandale ça a réveillé des
consciences chez vous c'était terrible
24 heures avant la fermeture la ministre
de la Culture a émis une hypothèse c'est
peut-être à cause de la concurrence du
commerce en ligne
waouh on est en 2013 Philippe ETTI
découvre Amazon
c'est dans deux ans elle arrive à poster
une vidéo sur facebook vraiment bravo
bravo Aurélie
je souhaite également une bonne année
2013 à la première manif de l'année
enfin première MAIF de l'année c'est le
machin contre le mariage pour tous ou
pour je sais plus très bien cette espèce
de CGT de la sexualité normative là qui
va battre le pavé enfin le grand défilé
pour la pénétration des orifices
socialement acceptables
au moins dans ce pays on a le sens des
priorités je me demande ça va être quoi
les slogans puisqu'on vous dit que c'est
pas le bon trou
la nuit c'est que pour le bonus
voire des cadeaux défilés contre le
mariage c'est à peu près aussi crédible
que de voir des végétariens humilité
pour la batajalal quoi c'est un truc
en tout cas la sexualité gay aura au
moins un mérite faire parler les cathos
de la leur ce qui va arrive assez
rarement dire en même temps je vois pas
très bien pourquoi il s'excite au sujet
de la PMA il fait pas retirer cette loi
c'est très bien la PMA en plus qu'est-ce
que c'est d'ailleurs la procréation
médicalement assistée c'est quoi c'est
faire l'amour avec en se faisant tenir
le sexe par Michel Cymes c'est ça le
moi je comprends pas d'ailleurs pourquoi
l'Église est contre la procréation
médicalement assistée je veux dire la
PMA c'est quoi c'est la procréation sur
le péché de l'acte c'est l'église
devrait être pourquoi c'est une sorte de
d'éjaculer conception quoi c'est
2013 je souhaite également que la presse
française soit un peu plus objectif si
elle pouvait enfin reconnaître que
Vladimir Poutine est un démocrate doublé
d'un humanisme non mais vous connaissez
beaucoup de présidents qui naturalise
dans l'étranger en trois jours
2013 le printemps arabe qui a donné sa
première récolte pas très convaincante
c'est un seul bizarre quoi c'est un sol
tu plantes de la démocratie pousse de la
charia
ferait peut-être mieux de planter de la
dictature aurait plus de chance de
retrouver de la démocratie quoi
ce qui m'amène au sujet des
décapitations en Arabie Saoudite
transition naturelle 76 décapitations en
2012 en Arabie Saoudite on s'y prend mal
pour exporter la démocratie fin dans ces
pays-là peut-être que si on leur
fournissait la guillotine il ferait le
lien avec la Déclaration des Droits de
l'Homme je sais pas
c'est plus intelligent que profond mais
faut terminer par une bonne nouvelle
peut-être Jack Lang qui a enfin trouvé
un point de chute l'Institut du monde
arabe
ça prouve donc que les rumeurs sur le
poste de garde champêtre place des
Vosges était fausse
puisqu'on vous dit que c'est les soldes
alors pas belle la vie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors ça y est c'est arrivé René Coty a
pété un câble il y a 6 mois il se
prenait pour Mitterrand maintenant il se
prend pour le maréchal Rommel
alors un type de la manif de dimanche
passé la comparé à Hitler bon c'est pas
c'est pas complètement faux le maïs
c'est quoi c'est une Pologne déshydratée
donc
alors historiquement la seule expédition
de l'armée française dans le désert
c'était Napoléon
fiasco total finalement alors voir
Hollande réussir là où Napoléon a échoué
c'est à peu près aussi probable que de
découvrir Ben Laden planqué dans la
grotte de Lourdes
alors il a appelé l'opération militaire
l'opération Serval alors c'est un félin
assez un petit félin qui est la
particularité de pisser 30 fois en une
heure pour marquer son territoire
comme quoi d'être intronisé sous la
pluie ça vous marque une présidence
[Musique]
alors évidemment branle-bas de combat le
ministre de la Défense annonce des raids
aériens sur le Mali ah bon il y a un
truc à bombarder là-bas
je sais pas tu montres une photo du Mali
avant les bombardements en général la
Deuxième Guerre mondiale il te répond
tiens bon travail quoi
toute la démesure française et là quoi
poursuivre des pick-up avec des mirages
et des rafales
alors de nombreux Français se posent des
questions la première est-ce que ces
stratégiques d'envoyer des hommes au
Mali ah bah évidemment le Mali c'est
stratégique c'est on peut pas faire
partie des grandes puissances mondiales
si on contrôle pas la production de
manioc et de patates douces c'est
évident alors la France a envoyé 1700
hommes est-ce que c'est suffisant
faisons un calcul rapide sachant qu'il
faut une équipe de 32 policiers durent
pour faire sortir de sa salle de bain un
type armée de deux Colt combien en
faut-il pour affronter 6000 djihadistes
trottant à l'air libre alors j'ai fait
le calcul 6000 fois 30 hommes ça fait
180 000 hommes au Mali combien la France
en a-t-elle envoyé 1700
bon alors l'autre question c'est combien
de temps va durer l'opération continuons
les calculs sachant qu'il a fallu 30
heures au policiers du Raid pour déloger
Momo de son hammam privatif
pour 6000 hommes cela fait donc 30
heures x 6000 hommes ce qui nous donne
240 000 jours donc 657 ans
Hollande ou l'Optimisme
alors bon attention on n'est pas les
seuls on a des renforts les Belges
j'envoie 75 soldats mais pas au front ah
non ça c'est pas c'est pour le soutien
moral je vois le truc tu vois il
viendront avec des banderoles allez les
bleus
mais bon en face les mecs c'est des
sérieux quoi c'est ils disent qu'ils
vont taper le cœur de la France on va
encore mal dormir à Tulle
de toute façon on s'y prend très mal
avec les islamistes contre des
fanatiques faut envoyer des fanatiques
c'est pas ce qui leur faudrait c'est pas
des légionnaires mais les mecs de
Civitas
en tout cas l'otage occidental à la côte
pour les islamistes les otages
catholiques se trompent peut-être de
religion mais en terme de valeur
marchande c'est du bien de luxe c'est au
Sahel l'otage occidental c'est comme
l'immobilier à Paris ça c'est des mots
de passe
alors évidemment une guerre c'est aussi
des familles déchirées et moi j'ai une
pensée émue pour toutes les femmes des
djihadistes restées derrière la ligne de
front ça doit pas être évident être une
femme de djihadiste c'est la nana qui
reçoit une lettre de son mec mon amour
je t'aime je pense à toi PS pourquoi tu
lis ces mots un pur chienne
sont en ce moment la France elle a un
truc avec les pays en Ali quoi Somalie
Mali enfin je serai l'Italie je me
méfierai un peu
alors on dit que l'opération est un
fiasco en Somalie c'est faux c'est un
plus dotage français c'est enfin plus
vivant
à force de faire ces bêtises au
lendemain de ma vie et Mamadou quoi
c'est
il en faut pour tout le monde
société alors la semaine passée a eu
cette manif je sais plus très bien
contre pour
Bertrand Delanoë réclame cent mille
euros pour les dégâts je suppose que
lors de la prochaine manifestation
promariage gay il demandera les numéros
de téléphone des manifestants
[Applaudissements]
moi j'étais extrêmement choqué par
certains slogans vraiment je zéro maman
c'est déprimant on voit qu'ils
connaissent pas ma mère alors
ikwin parce qu'ils sont pas entendus
c'est vraiment des Bleus en France il y
a encore des naïfs qui pensent qu'on
peut bloquer le pays sans bosser à la
SNCF
toi tu m'étonnes que Hollande irrésistes
à la pression de la rue dire c'est pas
très dur de résister à une manif de
droite il manif de gauche s'ils sont pas
entendus ils bloquent les métros là les
gens ils vont bloquer quoi ils vont
bloquer quoi l'accès à la Maison du
Chocolat et à petit bateau c'est ça le
façon on mélange tout entre le mariage
l'adoption la PMA de toute façon je me
suis demandé à quoi est-ce qu'on
reconnaît un enfant né sous PMA
c'est le mec qui crie maman quand il
voit une pipette
et qui fait une dépression quand il fait
des TP de chimie là il peut plus quoi
c'est
moi personnellement moi j'aimerais
vraiment être un enfant adopté quoi en
couchant avec des femmes 45 ans j'aurais
au moins l'espoir que l'une d'entre
elles soit ma mère
il y en a pour tous les goûts
façon moi il commence à me saouler avec
leur histoire de mariage toi même si
c'est légitime c'est vraiment c'est à
dire la réforme c'est moi je suis sûr
que le rêve de Rimbaud est Verlaine
c'est peut-être s'acheter un love dans
le marais et de louer le ventre de
George Sand pour y faire fructifier
l'embryon de Marcel Proust il y a des
évidences comme ça ça saute aux yeux
c'est c'est implacable après je
comprends que l'Église soit contre le
mariage gay c'est normal c'est normal ce
qui gêne l'Église c'est pas l'amour
entre deux hommes mais c'est que vu les
orifices concernés dans un couple homo
il est impossible de rester vierge
jusqu'au mariage
[Applaudissements]
je vois bien moi Benoît XV qui va bouger
son dogme pour faire plaisir à la
gayprade franchement faut se réveiller
quoi Benoît XVI qui est allé jusqu'à
citer le grand rabbin Bernheim pour
appuyer ses propos c'est étonnant c'est
étonnant ça c'est peut-être la première
fois qu'un Pape si tu es un juif en
dehors d'une préfecture de police
économie alors la période des soldes
continue chez Renault on va licencier
7500 ouvriers franchement quand on voit
la gueule de leur voiture ferait mieux
de licencier les mecs qui les dessine
[Applaudissements]
moi à chaque fois que je vois une
Renault je me dis que les types qui les
dessine sont des anciens de chez
Playmobil façon les futurs
concessionnaires ce sera JouéClub à mon
avis dans combien de temps c'est le
sport Armstrong c'est dopé je vois
vraiment pas où est le problème je veux
dire si tout le monde se dope à la fin
c'est quand même le meilleur qui gagne
faits divers alors c'est un mec qui est
resté mort pendant 36 heures dans les
toilettes d'un hôpital sans être
découvert alors peut-être que la lutte
contre les maladies nosocomiales ça
serait déjà de faire venir une femme de
ménage plus d'une fois par semaine
sinon
bonne nouvelle marseille capitale
européenne de la culture c'est la vanne
alors elle est pas belle la vie
[Applaudissements]
bonne année à tous
vous en avez assez de l'actualité et
bien moi je vous en débarrassé de cette
actualité de quoi était faite cette
semaine et bien les fêtes de cette chose
qui cause une indigestion sans avoir
besoin de passer par une huître périmée
ou une salmonelle je veux bien entendu
parler du mariage gay
ah le mariage gay ce sujet d'une
importance géopolitique considérable
sans laquelle nul société humaine serait
tournée proprement il faut pas oublier
que s'il y a une deuxième guerre
mondiale c'est parce que Hitler est
Staline auront pu leur PACS
on est haut de gamme on ne l'est pas
alors évidemment ça mérite bien qu'on y
consacre 6 mois de bruit une manif une
contre manif un débat l'Assemblée
nationale et à l'avenir qui sert un
référendum de coup d'état trois guerres
nucléaires et peut-être la reconduction
de Morandini à l'antenne l'année
prochaine
dans la foulée est Taubira lance la
polémique ça va être tobira l'éloquence
de Raoni sans le claquemaire d'intégrer
bref
polémique sur la naturalisation des
gosses pondus par des femmes étrangères
donc c'est ce qu'a lancé tobiral selon
Philippe etis ce n'est pas une
légalisation de la GPA de gestation pour
autrui non déjà c'est une grande
nouvelle en plus du ministère de la
Culture Philippe ETI 06 celui de la
puériculture
alors elle s'est expliqué c'est
simplement une régularisation pour 40
cas d'enfants qui aujourd'hui se trouve
dans une situation administrative Kaf
Cayenne la chance des gamins quand ils
seront adultes c'est peut-être les seuls
qui seront qui était Kafka
bravo à l'intérieur pendant ce temps et
bien valse a décidé de continuer à
expulser des imams à l'affiche du
territoire national [ __ ] je vais aller
prier où moi les vendredis quoi
moi j'adore le fils musulman ça c'est
enfin contrairement à l'office
catholique eux au moins ils ont la
pudeur de pas essayer de se faire
comprendre
et au fond c'est quoi le prêche d'un
salafiste c'est quoi on dirait de Joey
Starr qui c'est ça aura quoi c'est
passons à autre chose internationale
l'offensive malienne continue alors
contrairement à ce qu'on dit ça avance
mais c'est faux ça traîne quoi je veux
dire Montreuil n'est toujours pas tombé
Hollande vraiment c'est un live il
s'arrête à ton bouc tout au lieu de
faire quoi de continuer par le nord
prendre les Algériens à revers tomber
sur Alger reprendre la Casbah tu vois le
truc
depuis Alger attaqué la France on prend
le contrôle de Marseille
[Applaudissements]
c'est bon le maïs c'est l'un des pays
les plus pauvres du monde
classé 175e sur 182 en fonction de
l'indice de développement alors
évidemment c'est pas un classement
définitif tout peut changer c'est à dire
si un soldat français en mission perd
son iPhone le pays va gagner 10 places
alors c'est vrai que ça bouge beaucoup
en Afrique en ce moment il y a pas il y
a le mal il y a l'Egypte aussi l'Egypte
qui qui fait son mai 68 sous les pavés
la sauce Harissa très ça fait du bien
enfin des manifs ou les émeutiers ne
pourront pas se plaindre du racisme des
flics
nous devons comprendre après les autres
démerdez-vous
alors tout est parti d'un match de foot
assez sanglant alors franchement moi
j'ai revu les images il y avait pas
hors-jeu quoi c'était pas
si c'est un bordel pareil à cause d'un
match de foot imagine le jour ils feront
le mariage gay
toujours en Afrique le Zimbabwe il reste
217 dollars dans les caisses de l'État
en France il en manque un milliard
700000 enfin
pour une fois qu'on peut prendre exemple
sur l'Afrique profitons-en
international toujours Florence Casset
qui est revenu ouf on va enfin pouvoir
bouffer des pépitos la conscience
tranquille
avec
avec cette première conférence de presse
très très presse quoi très très je
cherche du travail
impressionnant j'ai tout de suite elle
pense aux choses concrètes de la vie
alors dans la foulée en deux jours elle
rencontrait Holland et Sarko comme quoi
on peut encore se faire un vrai réseau
en prison
culture
cette famille qui vient de se faire
virer d'un musée parce qu'elle sentait
mauvais moi je vois pas le problème quoi
là c'est un truc ça fait transpirer vous
le savez maintenant c'est c'est au moins
ils étaient émus comme moi perso que je
peux pas voir du Duchamp sans me chier
dessus quoi c'est
[Applaudissements]
Philippe ETTI très très en forme la
déclaré que la culture est un vecteur de
lutte contre les inégalités c'est vrai
on le dit jamais assez quoi c'est pas
par exemple tu vois un type qui est dans
la rue un SDF on devrait pas lui dire
vous avez froid non vous voulez une
couette
ou le best of des [ __ ]
là on fait quelque chose et quelque
chose
[Applaudissements]
la culture vecteur de lui contre les
inégalités qu'est-ce qu'on attend pour
bombarder Florange avec des toiles de
maître
faits divers
Yana Guillon qui s'est fait choper à la
douane en cette République Dominicaine
avec 11 kg de drogues dans ses valises
dans ses valises à ce niveau
d'amateurisme et désinvolture autant
essayer de passer la voile avec une
brouette un casque de chantier et dire
puisque je choisis que c'est du plâtre
quoi je veux dire que c'est pas
[Applaudissements]
sordide c'est une rubrique que j'ai
inventée comme ça
c'est une joggeuse qui s'est fait
dézinguer alors c'est un suspect qui a
été chopé alors selon les flics il ne
dit pas tout en bloc mais il ne
reconnaît pas tout on espère qu'il va
progresser c'est vraiment marrant les
psychopathes quoi il t'arrive à
t'expliquer comment on peut tuer
quelqu'un mais un peu
je termine par une bonne nouvelle en
général mais là j'en ai pas
alors pour une fois une mauvaise
nouvelle mais en souhaitant que le
devienne bonne qui sait c'est Zahia va
écrire un livre pour les enfants
ferait mieux de faire un film pour les
adultes
voilà merci c'était Gaspard
[Applaudissements]
salut Gaspard
ouais super super 2 mois en mer sans
ramener un poisson je vois pas l'exploit
[Applaudissements]
allez cette semaine alors qu'est-ce
qu'il y a comme info déjà périmé alors
première salle de shoot va ouvrir je
vois pas le problème je veux dire une
salle de shoot c'est quoi c'est une
pharmacie sans les produits inefficaces
alors dans la foulée Gilbert Collard
voyez le verger c'est l'aïoli propose
d'ouvrir des salles de crime de viol et
de vol il est un peu en retard connard
ça existe déjà ça s'appelle une prison
international le Mali bon alors la
guerre est gagnée c'était un peu
prévisible quand même on allait quand
même pas perdre qu'on dégâts qui savent
pas de se dessiner tout seul une carte
postale de l'UNICEF
le jour où on perdra contre le Mali il
nous restera plus qu'à nommer du flot au
gouvernement
oui ça c'est déjà fait
alors en guise de victoire au Mali
françois Hollande s'est vu offrir un
chameau
il a pas réagi il a pas réagi même quand
on gagne on arrive à se faire humilier
on a beau critiqué l'impérialisme
occidental à un moment on devrait aussi
s'insurger contre le profond manque
d'intérêt que nous portent les pays
pauvres
offrir un chameau un Français ils ont
déjà ouvert un livre de géo les Maliens
ils croient quoi qu'en France on a des
crocodiles dans la Seine et des
éléphants dans la galerie
non mais sans blague moi la prochaine
fois qu'un dirigeant du sel nous offre
un chameau on devrait lui livrer illico
un ours polaire
en plus me dire comme ça bol le chameau
un animal qui peut rester un mois sans
boire bon c'est pas on les libère d'un
tas de débile coraniques et nous en
guise de remerciement et nous offre une
gourde qui croque
moi je crois de toute façon le seul
avantage c'est intervention au malice
c'est que Vigipirate est en alerte
maximale et ça c'est moi Vigipirate je
suis à fond pour que ça ah ouais pour
une fois que ce pays a trouvé une façon
intelligente de fliquer les
fonctionnaires de la SNCF
vous savez comment recrute un soldat de
Vigipirate c'est on a réfléchi mais pour
toi c'est trop dangereux ton boucle
économie
alors Microsoft a décidé de lancer un
smartphone bon marché pour l'Afrique
on n'arrête pas le progrès reste plus
qu'à inventer l'adaptateur secteur qui
se branche directement dans le tas de
sable
culture
selon Johnny la gauche encourage la
médiocrité il aurait quand même pu
trouver une façon plus classe de dire
que ça l'avait fait chier de bosser avec
Obispo et chez lui
alors bon que la gauche je t'encourage
la médiocrité c'est une évidence il y a
qu'à voir dans quel état se trouve la
droite
culture toujours alors non rap enfin je
voulais mettre sur la rubrique culture
mais le rap c'est bien plus que ça c'est
de la culture c'est aussi du sport de la
religion et pas mal de handicap
bref
deux balles ont été tirés sur la voiture
du rappeur La Fouine alors ça s'est
passé à Saint-Maur-des-Fossés quoi bon
on a le Bronx ce qu'on mérite
ça mord des fossés c'est un peu Harley
avec des magasins de moquettes
Saint-Maclou
alors il y a pas de mort d'homme ça
c'est ça ça reste du gangsta rap à la
française on peut pas c'est
gesticulations d'un vendeur de boîte
avec la logistique du Val-de-Marne
on parle d'un réglement de compte je me
demande bien ce que deux rappeurs
peuvent régler comme compte en France à
part un dossier aux ASSEDIC ou le vol
d'un dictionnaire des synonymes
après je
comprends que la fouine accuse le coup
quoi c'est vrai qu'avec le nombre de
disques qui vend on se demande s'il
arrivera à payer sa facture chez
Carglass c'est
[Applaudissements]
autre fait divers Daniel Evenou en
maillot de bain sur TF1 oh là
oui je me commente pas la télé mais
quand il y a des vraies infos je pense
qu'on peut pas passer à côté alors
l'émission s'appelle splash le concept
des célébrités de premier plan
qui plonge dans une piscine bon on a mis
une piscine parce que si on l'avait mis
une cuvette des chiottes les vedettes ce
serait peut-être douter de quelque chose
c'est un peu la bouche allez goûter les
visuelle du has bebe franchouillard quoi
c'est vraiment du recyclage à côté le
loft c'est une émission d'Arte quoi faut
être honnête alors moi j'avais un autre
concept ça s'appelle bim bam boum c'est
comme splash mais avec une piscine vide
sport
football alors révélation d'une vaste
affaire de match truqué alors il paraît
que ça concerne pas la France c'est
normal vu le niveau intellectuel nos
joueurs c'est beaucoup trop complexe à
monter
c'est pas
je alors je sais que ça fait un peu
cliché d'illustrer cette idée par une
photo de Ribéry mais je vous jure il
suffit de l'écouter 15 secondes pour se
rendre compte que en fait non quoi c'est
c'est possible alors c'est très
révélation s'accompagne de force
soupçons de dopage dans le milieu du
foot pas en Ligue française ça c'est pas
ah non tu m'étonnes en France pour tenir
le coup c'est pas celui qui joue un
match qui doit se doper c'est celui qui
le regarde
[Applaudissements]
récemment la police a découvert 50 000
images pédophiles dans l'ordinateur d'un
commerçant à Toulon alors bon le type il
s'est défendu il a dit oui mais bon j'ai
consulté des sites une ou deux fois elle
aurait pu trouver autre chose quoi dire
moi quand je consulte en ligne mon
compte à l'UBS je me retrouve pas avec
50 000 photos de Jérôme Cahuzac à poils
sordide ce bébé mort dans le ventre de
sa mère faute de place pour le faire
accoucher à la maternité alors c'est
vrai que c'était ça beaucoup mobilisé
les gens très tristes les un peu dit
mais pourquoi pourquoi l'accouche enfin
le truc classique quoi et ben moi j'ai
compté le nombre de mois qui séparent
l'accouchement de l'acte et j'en suis
arrivé à la conclusion qu'en termes de
karma c'était pas idéal de copuler le
soir de l'élection de Flamby
alors peut-être une bonne nouvelle pour
terminer il y en a une vraiment la
vitesse sur le périph va passer de 80 à
70 km/h chouette on va enfin pouvoir
profiter du paysage alors
pas belle la vie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quoi de neuf bon ben c'était la
Saint-Valentin jeudi
m'a fait de préférer cette fête où je
pense il y a toutes ces femmes à qui
j'ai posé un lapin une veste et pour les
plus chanceux une blennorragie
parce qu'aujourd'hui j'ai envie de
donner je suis là
today Gaspard Proust challenge my life
[Musique]
en ce moment ah ouais le gouvernement
c'est le sociétal qui masque le social
au lieu de faire le mariage gay on
ferait mieux de résoudre le problème du
chômage hey
résoudre le chômage ça fait 30 ans qu'on
essaye un moment faut savoir perdre
[Applaudissements]
des trucs bien le mariage gay c'est
tellement enfin un gouvernement qui se
soucie d'amour d'amour [ __ ]
tu vois quoi l'amour quoi enfin le PS il
fournit l'amour la crise est fournit
l'eau fraîche quand on est pas bien
tu vois
[Applaudissements]
est-ce qu'il y a pas un moment où on
peut parler d'autre chose que de fric et
déficit on peut juste puis refuser la
PMA quelle connerie il faut faire des
gosses sinon qui va payer les dettes de
nos parents et c'est les vases bon pour
d'autres c'est une époque terrible c'est
vrai qu'on sent que les gens perdent
leurs repères parce que ce type qui
s'est immolé devant Pôle Emploi moi j'ai
eu très peur je dis ah non puis après je
dis c'est pas grave le pape n'est pas
bouddhiste donc
non mais franchement le type il se croit
ou au Tibet à Belleville le type il est
en France me faire le printemps arabe un
moment il faut choisir son camp alors
les gens sont choqués parce qu'il aurait
prévenu les gars de Pôle emploi et ces
derniers n'auraient rien fait pour
empêcher le massacre ils allaient quand
même pas intervenir à cause d'une torche
humaine quand pour une fois qu'il y
avait une lumière au Pôle emploi et
[Applaudissements]
les politiques dans tout ça que font les
politiques alors Hollande remonte dans
les sandales ça c'est grâce à la guerre
au mariage gay chacun son fond de
commerce c'était à Sarko l'identité
nationale Hollande l'amour sous les
douches bon
alors il se murmure que Sarko va revenir
en 2017 il est pas bien faire des
conférences à 100.000 euros et rêver de
rouler en BX
mais bon ça doit être un truc d'ego
c'est par rapport à la France c'est le
pouvoir c'est comme ça et puis voir
Hollande enfin c'est on regrette plus
facilement son ex quand on la retrouve
au bras d'un tocard c'est
[Applaudissements]
ils ont supprimé la faucille et le
marteau c'est vrai que vu que le PC
représente surtout des bataillons de
chômeurs ils auraient dû le remplacer
par une télécommande et un paquet de
chips ça aurait été c'était plus adapté
parlons de parlons de scolarité de
politique le 4 cet élève qui se faisait
harceler à l'école parce qu'il était
roux et il s'est suicidé vraiment
malheureuse histoire alors il se faisait
harceler depuis trois ans on reproche au
prof de pas avoir agi moi je comprends
pourquoi les profs ont laissé faire pour
une fois que c'est pas eux qu'on
caillasse il fallait bien
alors je pense à la prochaine rentrée
scolaire en salle des profs et toi cette
année ils sont comment avancer dure et
toi à moi ça va dans la classe il y a un
roux
handicap
je veux évidemment parler de foot
un international français serait un
nouveau impliqué dans une relation avec
une prostituée mineure alors le
footballeur joue dans le championnat
russe quoi un moment jouer en Russie et
se faire gauler avec une prostituée
française faut le faire c'est comme
aller un défilé Dior et rentrer avec
Cécile Duflot c'est l'intérieur
[Musique]
c'est pas le seul c'est un peu la saison
des footballeurs qui se fontgolais
Patrice c'est vrai lui c'est fait gauler
avec une escort-girl et les gens sont
étonnés ils comprennent pas c'est ils
pensaient quoi qu'il allait s'inscrire à
l'amour et dans le pré enfin je veux
dire on allait quand même pas le
retrouver avec une Femen vous savez
c'est les poussières sans l'oreille
musicale
alors elles ont fait une manif dans
Notre Dame de Paris alors c'est super
engagé c'est vrai que c'est vrai que le
vrai courage des Femen c'est qu'elles os
exhiber des poitrines qui feraient
débander des SK
mais oui moi je comprends qu'avec des
seins pareil on en veille à Dieu quoi
c'est
ça de grandir à l'ombre de Tchernobyl
ça pousse ou ça ne pousse pas
et si ça pousse
moi je comprends enfin c'est pas de la
provocat la provoque ça suppose un
danger quoi je veux dire traiter le pape
de nazi ou se promener nu dans une
église et c'était à la provocque que
l'accrobranche est à l'alpinie c'est de
l'adrénaline avec le confort bourgeois
quoi de la verveine au rhum faut arrêter
je veux dire ça alors certains se disent
mais pourquoi au lieu de faire du
tam-tam sur les cloches et font pas ça
dans une mosquée mais c'est pas possible
la cloche dans une mosquée ça s'appelle
un imam
[Applaudissements]
façon moins de taper une féministe n'a
jamais été un truc qu'on a féministe
c'est la féministe pour une lesbienne
c'est du gingembre et pour un mec c'est
du topinambour c'est pas un pôle emploi
Benoît XVI quel gâchis le pape donc
c'est ce type qui vient une fois par an
montrer au monde entier que le latin est
toujours mort
il parle 15 langues ce qui explique sans
doute pourquoi il n'aura jamais de pape
français
alors le type il a présenté sa démission
en latin preuve qu'il est complètement à
la rue parce que le type il gère deux
milliards de fidèles il s'adresse à 5
cardinaux et aux trois classes prépa en
Cocagne
en tout cas
c'est pas pour faire ma petite langue de
pupitre mais j'espère que le prochain
pape sera noir
ouais c'est juste pour voir si ceux qui
l'ont traité de nazis auront l'audace de
traiter le prochain zoulou
[Applaudissements]
gastronomie moi j'en peux plus le cheval
j'en peux plus quand je pense ça fait
une semaine que l'actualité monopolisé
par une [ __ ] de sauce bolognaise
l'Europe qui a la renverse à cause d'un
plat cuisiné enfin déjà le plat cuisiné
il faut voir ce que c'est c'est quoi
c'est c'est du vomi gratiné quand tu
vois
ce qui en mange en fait on vient de
sortir une Logan en plat cuisiné ça
s'appelle des lasagnes à la rouelle
les gens s'étonnent du caractère caché
ils auraient pu prendre le pli quand la
Roumanie c'est quand même tout ce qui
est un peu caché enfin je le slogan de
la Roumanie c'est quoi c'est quand c'est
roumain c'est clandestin
après on s'étonne que cette viande et le
goût de voyage enfin je suis désolé les
roulottes sont attirés par des Charolais
non c'est une polémique très indécente
sur la viande ça concerne surtout les
pauvres bon c'est eux qui achètent des
plats cuisinés bon et franchement être
au chômage et pas avoir le temps de
cuisiner
[Musique]
alors
bonsoir bonsoir
[Applaudissements]
c'est un jour l'histoire verra en vous
cet homme courageux et visionnaire
surtout si on découvre que vous avez
vendu l'hippodrome de Chantilly à
Spanghero
politique gauche alors ils ont nommé
Ségolène Royal comme porte-parole à la
tête de la Banque d'Investissement c'est
quand même la déchéance quoi vouloir
l'Assemblée nationale et finir comme
attaché de presse du Sofinco public
elle aurait plus de pouvoir comme PDG du
club de philatélie du 19e arrondissement
où gérant de la Coccimarket à Pontoise
alors bon elle se vendent de le faire à
titre gracieux sacré Ségolène stagiaire
et contente de l'être
toujours gauche Taubira qui dit que la
prison forme la délinquance elle est au
courant que lorsqu'on y rentre on a déjà
quelques bases
[Applaudissements]
alors bon c'est vrai que la prison c'est
peut-être pas la solution idéale pour le
délinquant en revanche pour le voisinage
sinon il y a du flow qui persiste dans
la réquisition des biens alors l'idée
est simple en gros tout bien qu'on
possède et qui n'est pas utilisé devrait
profiter à quelqu'un s'il fallait
réquisitionner toutes les choses vides
de ce pays
lire ma copine n'est pas pleine tout le
temps quoi
ce que je veux dire elle va pas tout le
temps au théâtre au cinéma il se cultive
pas quoi
public à des idées à son image voilà
droite alors les amis de Sarkozy se sont
réunis pour saluer le bilan de
l'ex-président alors quand on soutient
le bilan d'un type qui a perdu la
présidentielle les législatives les
européennes les municipales et les
régionales on est au moins sur d'une
chose ce sont de vrais amis
business
Maurice Taylor patron de titan alors
soyez jettent l'éponge sur les reprises
de Goodyear à Amiens il envoie une
lettre cinglante à Arnaud Montebourg
alors là on va sa tronche alors je lis
ce qu'ils disent c'est assez c'est assez
intéressant les salariés français
touchent des salaires élevés mais le
travail que trois heures ils ont une
heure pour leur poser leur déjeuner
discutent pendant trois heures et
travail 3 heures et à côté de la plaque
Maurice quand on vit en pleine
cambrousse picarde on a clairement pas
la matière suffisante pour soutenir
trois heures de conversation
[Rires]
voir Amiens et mourir ce qui est
toujours mieux que l'inverse mourir et
voir Amiens
à propos j'ai vu que PSA a fait une
perte de 5 milliards d'euros
à Aulnay on arrive peut-être pas à faire
des voitures à l'Allemand mais on arrive
à faire des pertes à l'américaine
non mais 5 milliards d'euros ils ont osé
faire autant de voitures
c'est pas de la viennoiserie enfin bon
c'est comme vous amour Jean-François
Copé veut reconstruire une relation
affective avec les Français non ça c'est
au rayon humour pardon
plomberie
Oscar Pistorius
pistorieux c'est le type qui est monté
sur des lattes de sommier
un pistorious moi la première fois que
je l'ai vu courir on dirait un nain qui
fait du trampoline tu sais c'est
en tout cas quand je vois à quoi ça mène
un handicapé qui a de l'argent moi
j'arrête de donner au Téléthon c'est
je plaisante j'ai jamais donné alors
je trouve l'affaire assez intéressante
c'est vrai qu'elle en dit long sur les
mœurs d'un pays assez méconnu l'Afrique
du Sud parce que Pistorius a raconté à
la barre qu'il a cru que c'était une
intrusion de domicile ça c'est tout le
charme de l'Afrique du Sud quoi là-bas
les voleurs sont mannequins et avant de
te cambrioler ils prennent une douche
enfin quand on voit à quoi ressemblait
le cambrioleur ça donne envie de les
laisser les clés sur la porte plus
souvent
de toute façon en Afrique du Sud on
parle pas à domicile mais c'est un
accident domestique quoi je veux dire la
balle pakistanais du coin ils vont pas
des roses mais des fusils d'assaut c'est
ancienne Saint-Denis en Afrique du Sud
ils sont comme un cadeau à Neuilly
à côté de pretorial La Courneuve c'est
une station balnéaire
voyage une aire d'accueil va être créée
pour les gens du voyage dans le bois de
Boulogne alors on joue avec le feu quoi
c'est vraiment le moment de voir le
virus du sida fusionner avec les germes
de la tuberculose
[Applaudissements]
humanisme toujours la SNCF lance le TGV
low cost ça va s'appeler ouigo alors
déjà une certitude l'agence de pub aussi
et locos
dire quitte à faire de l'anglais
phonétique vu la fiabilité légendaire de
la SNCF autant ne pas faire publicité
mensongère quoi ouigo mais oui
alors le low cost touche aussi le
secteur du tourisme surtout dans les
régions africaines un peu tendues alors
ça c'est cette nouvelle forme de voyage
lancée par des agences comme
otages sans frontières voyages et
kidnapping alors c'est des voyages
tellement locaux ce que ce sont les
seuls où on paye l'allée et l'État se
charge du retour
au fond une prise d'otage c'est quoi
c'est c'est le dépaysement de rencontre
en terre inconnue sans un présentateur
pénible
[Applaudissements]
cette semaine une bonne nouvelle une
mauvaise nouvelle un choix bonne
nouvelle on va apprendre le breton à
Sciences Po ouais c'est vrai que pour
lutter contre la mondialisation rien de
tel qu'ouvrir un master en galette
mauvaise nouvelle de la semaine les
morpions sont en voie d'extinction c'est
vraiment dommage c'était une occasion si
sympathique d'offrir à sa compagne un
animal domestique un peu de frais
alors pas belle la vie
[Applaudissements]
ça va ouais
super avec joie allons-y
alors je l'ai pas vu c'est que
totalement gratuit ce que je veux dire
c'est mais à l'heure du tout payant un
peu de gratuité dans l'humour ne fait
pas nécessairement de mal les Césars qui
se pavanaient parce qu'ils accueillaient
Kevin Costner ça c'est vrai c'est du
rêve du glamour je rappelle qu'à
l'époque de Danse avec les loups Édith
Cresson était premier ministre
ça c'est la France c'est la France et à
Hollywood que la province est à Paris on
a l'impression d'avoir Al Pacino alors
que nous a envoyé Évelyne Leclerc
engagement semaine difficile la France a
perdu Stéphane Hessel je pense que tout
le monde voit le Père Castor du lieu
commun engagé
Stéphane Hessel un mec tellement engagé
que lorsqu'il est né il portait déjà un
nom qui évoquait les poilus
indignez-vous indignez-vous qui disait
c'est vrai la paix c'est mieux que la
guerre le bien est supérieur au mal le
capitalisme c'est caca oups zut crotte
flûte il est l'heure de changer mes
couches ah le grand âge ce coma éthique
sans alcool en tout cas c'est un triste
des stars franchement révélé à 92 ans
mort à 95 3 ans de célébrité
dans son malheur une chance trop âgé
pour faire splash
bon je dis ça moi son bouquin à son
fascicule j'ai adoré à ton jamais rendu
un si bel hommage à du élevé tika police
pour une fois que la littérature
s'engage aussi sincèrement contre la
presbytie pourquoi bouder notre plaisir
alors de toute façon c'était un
résistant assez un gage d'Inata kabilité
en France je veux dire en France pour
pouvoir dire n'importe quoi c'est simple
en 40 et 45 soit tu as fait le mariole
dans le maquis soit à planquer des Juifs
dans ta cave c'est tu vois une fois que
tu as fait ça même si tu te mets à
raconter que la terre est plate tout le
monde va te trouver génial c'est
comme ça comme ça qu'est-ce que tu veux
Christine c'est comme ça en fait penser
à Nina Hagen jeune
bref politique gauche rien à dire ils
sont impeccable certes le chômage bat un
nouveau record mais il faut être honnête
c'est un peu trop tôt pour mesurer les
effets du mariage gay sur l'emploi
j'adore ce pays droite on a eu des
nouvelles de François Fillon alors lui
il a trouvé un nouveau truc monté sur
des tribunes convoquer des réunions pour
expliquer pourquoi il se rend candidat à
rien François Fillon ou l'homme qui
émane pas être là alors il paraît qu'il
va à la rencontre des Français il va
labourer le pays aller à la rencontre
des vrais gens c'est un peu le Light
motivé comment peut-on vouloir être
proche des gens en oubliant que la vraie
souffrance c'est de ne pas trouver de
taxi à deux heures du matin un samedi
boulevard Saint-Germain
Marine Le Pen
Marine Le Pen aimerait qu'on reconnaisse
aussi le caractère parfois utile de la
colonisation de la pâte tout à fait tort
la colonisation c'est un peu comme la
torture en Algérie on n'est pas sûr que
les bourreaux vont te laisser un bon
souvenir en revanche on est sûr qu'ils
vont te laisser un compteur EDF
économique alors le patron de Coca-Cola
est venu au secours de la France et ses
ouvriers et il a dit que les Français
travaillent bien plus que 3 heures par
semaine tu m'étonnes qu'il est ravi avec
la main de française je rappelle que son
métier consiste à faire des bulles
faut être honnête impasse payant veut
réformer les vacances d'été qui est
quand même fou quoi supprimer la
dernière raison valable qui donne envie
de faire prof
alléger les semaines alléger le
programme alléger les devoirs à la fin
il sortira plus des élèves mais de la
Spartan quoi ça sera le goût de
l'intelligence avec 0 % de culture
générale de danse et voilà l'avenir
romantisme DSK
alors une ex maîtresse de DSK qui pour
un énième bouquin sur lui alors c'est
écrit par Marcela Iacub je crois qu'on
voit la photo c'était voilà Diam's après
une chimio alors attention la fille
c'est pas n'importe qui c'est chercheuse
au CNRS tout ça c'est rassurant quoi ils
montent en gamme quoi de la femme de
ménage à la philosophe c'est la preuve
qu'il aurait fait un bon président quoi
il arrive à pénétrer toutes les couches
sociales c'est
[Applaudissements]
j'y pense 7 mois de relation pour
retranscrire des ébats sur le papier
comme quoi être chercheuse au CNRS c'est
pas forcément un gage de rapidité
d'esprit quoi
et tout ça au final pourquoi la nana
elle est tellement romancière du
dimanche qu'au bout de trois pages ta
pigé qu'ils agissaient de DSK quoi
du coup forcément une amende de 60 000
euros c'est vraiment le coup de maître
il va lui rester un sacré pactole à la
fin à la meuf quoi tu vois nafissato en
7 minutes elle touche le jackpot l'autre
elle met 7 mois à pondre un truc qui lui
fera toucher à peine de quoi souffrir un
abonnement au club medjim quoi c'est
avec
[Musique]
merci pour cette spontanéité
alors il y a cette alors évidemment
l'avocat a négocié un truc génial c'est
qu'il faut faire figurer la mention
atteinte à la vie privée alors sa
figurer dans chaque exemplaire du livre
ça c'est vraiment la victoire de DS quoi
le type il se bat pour cette dignité et
son avocat obtient que dans chaque
bouquin on disait lecteur ouais ouais le
gros porc c'est bien mon client
voilà alors bonne nouvelle de la semaine
passez la fin de la chronique quoi pour
vous je sais pas mais pour moi il y a
pas photo
alors
[Musique]
souriant ce soir je souris mais c'est
dur de se remettre à la fois du départ
du pape et de la mort de Stéphane Hessel
c'est vrai enfin je plaisante c'est pas
pas je veux dire le pape c'est dur pour
une fois qu'on avait un pape un peu
poétique c'est un puceau qui va
expliquer aux Africains la sexualité en
latin
mais sans plus attendre passons en revue
cette semaine tellement incroyable
passionnante où chacun dans son travail
et d'autres dans leur chômage on peut
méditer cette phrase dessus Oran à quoi
bon
politique alors Véronique Genest se
lance dans l'arène alors la déclaré un
truc formidable
je ne suis ni raciste ni xénophobe je
suis agnostique et la séparation de
l'État et de la religion me va bien
une phrase qui est à peu près autant de
sens que de déclarer je ne suis
allergique ni au gluten ni aux huîtres
je prends dans le cul et l'ouverture des
magasins le dimanche ça me convient
[Applaudissements]
cela dit moi jeunesse je l'envir elle
boit pas et pourtant elle a l'air tout
le temps bourré donc c'est un peu
autre femme de la semaine Ségolène Royal
qui nous gratifie du fulgurance les
femmes sont de meilleure gestionnaires
que les hommes c'est normal elle gagne
moins donc elles sont obligées de
[Musique]
qui justifie le truc voyez-vous Frédéric
Lefebvre elle dit
les femmes ont l'habitude de gérer un
budget familial alors je lui rappelle
qu'en général budget familial c'est
juste une autre manière de dire salaire
du mari
donc elle est nommée à la BPI là elle va
faire gestion des finances
la seule expérience c'est quoi gérer le
Poitou-Charentes ça doit pas être très
compliqué je veux dire entre feeling une
subvention tous les quatre ans avant des
globes et payer la blanchisserie de
Passe-Partout à Fort Boyard c'était pas
être
c'est pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
une ligne de bijoux style esclave a été
lancée enfin moi j'étais extrêmement
content mais évidemment ça fait
polémique dans ce pays tout de suite
c'est très mal vu d'être à la fois
soumis et coquet
alors qu'il y a du progrès pour une fois
qu'on propose des bracelets en or donc
quelque chose d'hypoallergénique je veux
dire esclave peut-être mais sans tétanos
alors c'est sûr bien sûr que
l'esclavagisme ce n'est pas bien c'est
vrai c'est vrai que c'est un vivre
ensemble qui ne laissait que peu de
place au dialogue social entre employé
et patron
après on peut dire ce qu'on veut mais
eux au moins ils avaient un travail
c'est factuel c'est pas moi c'est les
chiffres
d'où la question vaut-il mieux être
libre et chômeur ou esclave et occupé
international
j'avais des morts
le mannequin Go Sport bariolet alors
espèce de Kim jong-île qui fait la
lambada alors quand même deux ans de
combat contre le cancer et il ne l'a pas
vaincu ça c'est quand même dommage ça
aurait fait un chouette invité de 3e
partie c'est
vrai c'est vrai quand même l'ironie de
l'histoire pour un gauchiste
altermondialiste succombé un cancer du
colon
en jogging c'est soit il est malade soit
il est fou donc c'était un peu
alors mercredi il paraît qu'en dépit de
la mort de Chavez les marchés n'ont pas
plongé
ça a marché financier qui plonge après
la mort d'un marxiste c'est
tout il y a pas de blague je trouvais ça
très bien
alors le seul talent de Chaves aurait
beaucoup de gens qui qui chouinent enfin
c'est quoi c'est de savoir ouvrir une
PIPA fioul enfin je veux dire le
Venezuela c'est quoi c'est un Qatar
laïque ça va c'est un chèque jobiJoba
un pompiste avec un treillis 5 étoiles
j'espère qu'il apprendra au moins un
truc à l'extrême gauche l'avenir c'est
pas les agées branlettes dans un atelier
carrosserie mais les gaz de schiste
c'est ça le vrai truc Mélenchon qui
chiale parce que j'avais des parties
c'est vrai qu'on a perdu le soleil de la
cordillère le cheerleader de la pompe à
fuel Mélenchon il en est toujours aux
années 60 c'était terrible Mélenchon on
dirait vraiment un minitel déguisé en
Macbook c'est un truc
international toujours on a tué des
chefs salafistes au Mali
cocktails tu vois des trucs
après le Bloody Mary le Mokhtar
Belmokhtar on the caillou enfin bref
c'est tout
[Applaudissements]
le gouvernement de bonne raison de
penser que les otages français sont
toujours en vie je serai de la famille
de ces otages méfierai parce qu'un
gouvernement qui certifie la vie d'otage
mais qui est incapable d'authentifier la
mort des responsables c'est un moment
je m'interrogeais quoi
quand on commence à s'interroger on se
dit que quatre soldats français mort au
Mali
comme quoi c'est moins dangereux que la
Corse
[Applaudissements]
rubrique femme pourquoi pas
alors cette semaine encore un sondage on
demande aux Français quelle est leur
femme politique préférée deux femmes au
top Christine Lagarde et Marine Le Pen
la gérante d'agence bancaire et la
gugtère de la police des frontières
alors ça s'explique autant une française
qui a réussi à New York c'est
impressionne autant une bretonne qui a
échoué chez les Chtis attendri c'est
médical
Hollande a réussi avec succès son examen
biologique et médical alors s'il fait
tout comme Mitterrand il a donc un
cancer de la prostate
Marisol torrent demande une enquête sur
la cigarette électronique c'est vrai
qu'il y a des vrais sujets en France en
ce moment à quand le livre noir du
smecta le rapport annuel sur le talc
moi je peux déjà donner les conclusions
de l'enquête la cigarette électronique
est moins nocive que cigarette normale
mais utilisé comme une pioche elle peut
causer la mort
mobilité alors grâce à un nouveau métro
on pourra se déplacer facilement d'une
ville de banlieue à une autre sans
passer par la capitale enfin un geste
pour l'économie parallèle d'un métro qui
relie Saint-Denis au Blanc-Mesnil il
reste plus qu'à créer une station RATP à
Fleury-Mérogis
et qu'on a un mix après la marinière
Arnaud Montebourg fait la promotion de
la chaussette d'Alsace et publie une
photo sur Twitter depuis sa rupture il
brasse
mixeur marinière chaussettes plus que de
redresser la frange j'ai l'impression
qu'il postule à La Redoute quoi
justice une mère de famille condamnée
pour avoir prénommé son fils néan 11
septembre jihad alors il dit que c'est
un nom classique mais c'est vrai bah
voyons c'est un peu comme crucifix chez
les catholiques ou nunchaku chez les
Japonais
[Applaudissements]
alors deux bonnes nouvelles ah déjà par
quoi on va finir alors oui hier c'était
la journée de la femme oui on a donc une
année pour l'oublier et s'en remettre
et l'alcool tue 49000 français chaque
année
c'est oubli un peu vite tous les gens
qui ne seraient pas conçus sans lui
alors elle est pas belle
bonsoir
[Musique]
alors une pensée émue pour cette
automobiliste ce naufragé de la route
coincé avec deux enfants et qu'on a pu
sauver et oui la France est en crise
faute de moyens pour s'acheter un frigo
les gens sont réduits à profiter de la
météo pour tenter d'assassiner leur
mieux
oui car le drame majeur de la semaine
c'est de l'eau de l'eau gelée Dieu trop
occupé à se choisir un délégué terrestre
à part inadvertance mi la France au
congel résultat
politiquement conséquent redoutable
mercredi alors qu'il avait arrêté de
neiger depuis 24 heures Jean-Marc
Ayrault prévoyait face à la neige et au
verglas encore 48 heures difficiles
pauvre Jean-Marc encore un peu il nous
donnera les coefficients des marées les
risques d'avalanches et l'horoscope
héros qui appelle à la patience et à la
vigilance moi je je n'en peux plus
pourquoi dans ce pays à chaque fois
qu'il y a un nuage un peu chargé qui
passe j'ai l'impression d'être en
maternelle je veux dire c'est genre truc
qui me donne envie d'être Premier
ministre tu vois moi Premier ministre je
vois le blizzard qui arrive je balance à
la France entière demain verglas et
chute de neige surtout n'oubliez pas vos
tongs et vos paréo peut-être débile
alors que les mecs ils font une cellule
de crise la WAR room consacrée au grésil
et overglas avec Hollande qui promet des
mesures exceptionnelles en temps de
crise on arrive à trouver exceptionnelle
le déploiement d'une pelleteuse et d'un
chassenet
alors c'est que le début je sens que
Hollande va jouer les gros bras contre
la chargement météorologique vivement
qu'il nous montre les crocs face à la
canicule contre le temps qui passe le
saignement des gencives quand on se
brosse les dents enfin tout le moi
personnellement j'aime beaucoup les
catastrophes météorologiques
parce que sans catastrophe
météorologique aurait-on la chance de
voir passer dans les yeux de Delahousse
la menace soudaine que représente pour
lui Laurent Romejko
pendant ce temps là 1800 km c'était
étrange rassemblement de des milliers de
personnes se sont réunis place
Saint-Pierre pour s'extasier devant un
pot d'échappement braqué vers le ciel
alors ça c'est la force de la religion
catholique un crée de la ferveur grâce à
l'évaporation d'un bain-marie
ça vaut ce que ça vaut mais un peu de
galéjade de temps en temps bien sûr mes
amis alors bon moi j'étais très inquiet
deux fois la fumée noire puis ouf la
fumée blanche le pape est blanc
non s'il vous plaît
[Applaudissements]
je dis ça c'est pas
un pape noir c'est pas encore possible
l'église n'est pas encore prête pour
avoir un pape hétéro
[Applaudissements]
alors je dis ça beaucoup de catholiques
vont dire que c'est complètement gratuit
c'est vrai
mais Dieu est amour et Dieu même donc
faites pas chier
non mais c'est vrai que c'est très
pénible ce procès en pédophilie
permanent on juge au lieu de comprendre
la pédophilie existe peut-être mais
n'est-ce pas d'abord un résultat de
l'environnement avez-vous déjà vu le
plafond de la chapelle Sixtine les seuls
mec à poil c'est des anges
alors le pape s'appelle yorghem
arioberolio c'est le premier pape avec
un nom d'avance au centre du Barça
[Applaudissements]
je dis tout ça évidemment j'aime
beaucoup le pape c'est comme le jean
successeur du surréalisme c'est le seul
type au monde qui est capable de se
promener au milieu des guerres de la
misère et de la souffrance tout en
disant je vous annonce une bonne
nouvelle le Christ est joie
à peu près autant d'intérêt que traiter
un cancéreux aux huiles essentielles
mais enfin façon international à
Shanghai des milliers de cochons morts
sont repêchés au fil du fleuve après
vérification il s'agirait de la
livraison qu'attend défendus pour ces
boîtes de macro à l'huile
[Applaudissements]
restons dans le comestible si vous le
voulez bien alors c'est peut-être de
l'intox voire du Botox les condamnés
chinois exécutés se retrouvent dans des
crèmes des crèmes ouais ouais bon
d'habitude on met de la baleine et du
phoque pour une fois qu'on recycle les
vrais coupables
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
eux au moins ils ont une vraie politique
de répression
lion à la ville pas le pas l'animal qui
fait miaou bien sûr Lyon
un homme qui jette de l'acide sur trois
prostituées c'est quand même terrible
les ravages de la malbouffe sur la
qualité du sperme
[Applaudissements]
tu as compris le truc
ça c'est culture
culture donc télévision et je trouve que
la qualité des programmes télé a
fortement augmenté je suis tombé sur
confession intime enfin documentaire qui
vous réconcilie avec l'idée qu'il
faudrait donner des allocations
familiales en priorité aux familles qui
décident de ne pas avoir d'enfants
à votre service une bonne nouvelle
peut-être bon le Figaro nous apprend que
le tourisme en Syrie s'est effondré
maintenant plus aucune excuse pour ne
pas aller au Seychelles alors elle est
pas belle la vie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
salut salut
alors cette semaine j'aimerais
m'adresser directement au président de
la République
mon petit René Coty d'amour ma nouille
ma quenelle ma béchamel moi j'ai de
l'affection pour toi tu sais j'en ai
marre de te voir maltraiter comme un
punching-ball médiatique un flanc qu'on
démoule et qu'on roule [ __ ] t'es pas
une languette mon flambouille
je te vois j'ai l'impression d'être moi
Hugolin toi Jean de Florette qui tourne
comme un con autour de la source de ta
popularité sans jamais la voir mais
reste que tu es quoi te laisse pas
bousculer par le monde
dis-leur ce que tu as dans les tripes on
me demande de parler aux Français mais
pour leur dire quoi moi je vais bien
je n'ai jamais été aussi bien
entre proche de pas faire comme les
bosses mais tu as raison surtout refuse
la compétitivité fait du bas de gamme le
low cost c'est l'avenir tu crois pas que
dans cette mondialisation la vraie
jouissance c'est d'être trop cheap pour
un indien
mais non les applaudissements après
m'explane t'empêche pas de nous
surprendre ma France oui on te reproche
ton manque d'autorité prend une mesure
forte augmentons salaire et va plus loin
fais-toi voter un parachute doré en cas
de défaite au prochain président
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est gentil pour lui
tu as peut-être renoncé aux 3% de
déficit en 2013 mais crois-moi atteindre
les 3% de satisfait dans les sondages
c'est à t'apporter
et surtout une désespèrent jamais de la
météo tu dois tout le ciel est avec toi
même le pape porte ton nom [ __ ] quoi
crazy
regarde comme tu as été bon quand les
éléments naturels ont été défavorables
ça cartonné comme jamais été
Dream des pneus neige
mi printemps annonce le dégel
mi-novembre le grand froid à l'aube de
l'été kriger à la canicule moi président
enfin je le crois d'ici le 21 novembre
au plus tard je rétablirai l'hiver pour
tous
[Applaudissements]
à cet effet nomme un ministre attitré à
la course du soleil dans le ciel je sais
pas moi Najat VELUX Belkacem un truc
comme ça
je fais des jeux de mots alors
parce que mon petit René Coty électro
mon chat caponck de la Troisième
République taquis pour te barrer la
route les seuls qui font opposition
c'est quoi c'est les trois excités de
SUD Rail et encore on se demande si
c'est pas juste pour tester faire la
maintenance de l'hygiaphone quoi c'est
rien de très sérieux tu me diras la
droite mais quelle droite à Paris ils
vont présenter koscius comorisé tes Luma
Thurman en Barbour là
Lucrèce Borgia de Longjumeau mais à part
dans le 16e et le septième elle va
cartonner où dans une cave du 20e
pourquoi je sombre dans le sordide
quelle est cette violence qui me pousse
à démolir les gens
le plaisir sans doute
Fillon pas mieux tu vois Fillon il fera
quoi bon Fillon tu vois héro avec du
fric il est où qu'est-ce qu'il fait on
sait pas il ouvre un magasin d'articles
de pêche il s'est mis dans la socquette
anglaise moi je sais pas moi il fait des
Marines Le Pen on dit qu'elle monte bah
quel monte après tout serait quand même
dommage d'avoir la crise économique des
années 30 sans le folklore du claquement
de bottes
et puis Copé
déjà le type qui n'a même pas besoin
d'être président pour être détesté par
80% des Français t'imagines s'il était à
ta place
intellectuellement l'UMP est morte
depuis que kestrosi Morano et Lefebvre
la boucle l'UMP est en panne d'idée
la matière grise il y a que ça qui fait
tourner le monde
Sarkozy non plus plus personne n'en veut
enfin le mannequin de céréban Rolex
police municipale new-yorkaise sa
dernière lubie c'est d'éviter prendre le
contrôle d'un fond d'investissement
qatari mais la France voudra jamais d'un
président musulman
[Applaudissements]
tu sais François t'as fait des trucs
bien dans ton intuition géniale tu
resteras l'homme la délocalisation des
idées de gauche à Mélenchon bah ouais le
hibou écarlate si ça la muse se branler
sur Karl Marx
et surtout garde Jean-Marc Ayrault il
est génial il sert à rien pour une fois
que les chômeurs ont un Premier ministre
qui s'identifiez
parce que mon loulou ton truc toi c'est
la distance c'est toi tu es pas le
président de la CIC Sarkozy mais le
prince du bizut tantrique tu es un mec
tellement évanescent que tu arriverais à
faire jouir une nana à 10 mètres de
distance juste en lâchant une caisse
alors
alors mon François est pas belle la vie
[Musique]
super retour du prince en exil alors
Sarko alors il fait ça très très fin
quoi subtilement il délègue aux autres
Sarko il se mouille pas c'est vas-y
vas-y la Libye qui parle de sa stature
internationale le Qatar qui parle de sa
stature économique le juge Gentil qui
parle de son statut juridique
bon Nicolas est mis en examen pour abus
de faiblesse je suis désolé ça c'est un
peu normal quoi je vois pas très bien
comment on peut devenir président de la
République sans abuser de la faiblesse
des électeurs enfin c'est c'est dans le
package que ça de toute façon les gens
sont méchants qu'est-ce qu'ils sont
méchants avec Nicolas pour une fois
qu'il aurait abusé d'un riche hey quoi
je veux dire mais ça c'est la super
hérité de la gauche sur la droite quoi
c'est la gauche et la rive aussi abusé
de la faiblesse des pauvres c'est
alors
en même temps Nicolas il se fout le
patron quoi son seul argument de défense
et de ses potes c'est mais ce que vous
m'imaginez arnaquer une vieille dame
bah évidemment
dans tes capables d'installer des tentes
à Kadhafi dans les jardins de l'Élysée
pour lui sucer des contrats commerciaux
et tu serais pas capable d'aller faire
les poches et le mamie du caca 40 et que
faut se réveiller quoi je veux dire
alors il y a la présomption d'innocence
il y a pas il aurait
moi je veux bien à part pour du blé je
vois pas très bien l'intérêt d'aller
passer du temps avec une mémé quoi
en plus qu'est-ce qui va lui raconter
enfin je veux dire lui qui arrive pas à
rester en place trois secondes je
l'imagine mal passé une après-midi avec
une mémé qui a besoin de 20 minutes pour
terminer une phrase c'est
alors à droite tout de suite le scandale
scandale Nadine Morano compare cette
affaire au scandale d'Outreau
heureusement qu'elle a jamais eu envie
de faire une carrière judiciaire elle
puisque
juge d'instruction elle serait capable
de dire dans cette famille le problème
ce ne sont pas les parents pédophiles
c'est les enfants gérontophile
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors Sarko qui a déclaré la pluie finit
toujours par laisser la place au soleil
maintenant au moins on sait qui est le
parolier de Carla Bruni
Jean-Marc Ayrault a lancé une
mobilisation générale pour l'emploi et
Jean-Marc Ayrault
qui pousse un cri de mobilisation c'est
à peu près aussi crédible que de voir le
pape inauguré une partouze
l'Europe tremble parce que Chypre
s'effondre mais franchement Chypre quoi
alors évidemment tout le monde se
scandalisé tout le monde s'agit oui mais
c'est un scandale maintenant eux aussi
ils ont droit à l'austérité moi je vois
pas le problème là aussi si on applique
l'austérité à Chypre ils vont revenir à
ce qu'il faisait avant
la feta est désherbes de Provence
pas du coup ça fait beaucoup jaser
Mélenchon Mélenchon qui traite les
ministre de finances de l'Euro-groupe de
17 salopards 17 salopards on voit que
niveau cinéma au Front de gauche sont
encore des séances de rattrapage c'est
pas en tout cas Mélenchon au niveau
sémantique parce qu'elle a fait des
petites phrases genre année 30 tout ça
un peu des trucs que même le fnose plus
hein même le FN mais le F1 il a perdu
toute sa verve quoi aujourd'hui c'est le
FN c'est quoi c'est métallique à qui
changent de Jenifer
ça ça fait plus
parlant de mœurs musicales des pravés
mariage gay
bon personnellement je pensais qu'on
avait fait le tour du sujet qu'on
l'avait compris mais là non non là ça
continue du mariage gay il faut une
manif avec ce truc façon la droite fait
vraiment fait vraiment n'importe quoi
moi je veux pas être celui qui rajoute
de l'hépatite sur la GPA mais
cette manif avait des relents très
réactionnaires très
nauséabond quoi très ouais ouais gazer
des mioches je veux dire en plus
catholique
il y a eu cette photo terrible de
boutain au sol comme ça au milieu
valorizontal c'est pas son truc quoi je
sais pas
parlons de PMA encore une histoire de de
bébé congelé ce qui me choque toujours
dans ces histoires c'est pas tant
l'infanticide que la congélation
pourquoi la mer congèle son gosse
non mais elle attend une offre de
Spanghero
[Applaudissements]
alimentation toujours alors on a
retrouvé une souris morte dans un sachet
de pâtes alors forcément l'acheteuse
tout de suite voilà comme les réactions
c'est dégueulasse
elle a une idée du prix de la viande
pour une fois qu'on lui fournit des
protéines en arabe
moi je réponds des années j'enverrai une
facture
économie normale alors l'Allemagne s'en
sort mieux c'est normal quand tu as
perdu deux guerres de suite tu te remets
peut-être plus facilement en question
économie parallèle l'attaque du RER D
dans ce pays même les délinquants
perdent le boulot dire moi j'ai regardé
vous savez de d'où elle va le truc qui
relie Saint-Denis à l'Essonne
Saint-Denis à l'Essonne le machin le
plus friqué qu'elle traverse ces
Châtelet-les-Halles qu'est-ce que tu
braques à Châtelet-les-Halles le relais
façon je me disais contre la délinquance
dans ce pays on a tout essayé mais pas
la charia
non parce que si on commence à couper un
bras à chaque délinquant en termes de
réinsertion à part faire Captain crochet
dans la parade chez Mickey et
encore je pense pas au multirécidiviste
eux ils n'auront qu'une possibilité de
réinsertion le foot mais comme ballon
c'est les hommes troncs qui rebondissent
dans les filets quoi
culturellement
semaine difficile on a perdu Koh-Lanta
tout ça parce qu'un candidat est mort
bon fallait s'y attendre quoi force de
se faire bouffer fallait bien que les
asticots prennent le rebranche un jour
c'est
le type le premier jour il arrive il met
les pieds dans l'eau bam quoi le mec
vraiment pas doué pour faire touriste
quand même
ascenseur social il y a encore des
possibilités de promotion dans ce pays
Gad Elmaleh sort avec Charlotte
Casiraghi c'est à dire
encore un peu de patience on aura le
prince de Monaco
[Applaudissements]
ceci dit je m'inquiète le grand-père qui
est sorti à Grace Kelly la fille avec
Vincent Lindon la petite fille Gad
Elmaleh ouzenex
cigare et sa copine ont un gosse il va
sortir avec qui
Nabilla
Kev Adams
guerre la Corée menace d'attaquer les
États-Unis la Corée les États-Unis alors
ils ont envoyé Denis Rodman grand
basketteur là pour pour faire une
médiation je comprends que les coréens
se vexent quoi c'est quand l'Amérique
envoie comme représentant officiel un
ancien basketteur habillé comme un
dictateur zaïrois enfin je même nous on
n'a pas eu l'idée d'envoyer Philippe
Katerine négocier avec ACMI
[Rires]
match de foot français-espagne 1 France
0 alors Hollande qui a prédit un match
nul ah c'est tout lui ça si c'est nul
c'est bien avec l'huile essentielle
c'est pas de gagner mais pas perdre tout
seul
[Applaudissements]
je ne pensais mieux quand même pour
l'Espagne quoi c'est émouvant si l'avion
d'espagnol il se crache le pays il perd
la moitié de son PIB quoi
puis les footballeurs quoi c'est moi je
veux pas les dénigrer pour une fois
qu'on voit des milliardaires sué comme
des manutentionnaires quoi c'est le
footballeur c'est un peu le 2 en 1 de la
lutte des classes l'arrogance du
patronat avec le mauvais goût de la
classe ouvrière
bonne nouvelle ah oui il faut bien
terminons en beauté alors j'ai vu ça
dans le Figaro du mercredi la manchette
suivante les trois dernières semaines
pour diminuer votre ISF enfin
heureusement qu'il y a encore une presse
optimiste dans ce pays alors pas belle
la vie
[Applaudissements]
politique alors petit rappel la semaine
dernière le chef de l'État a parlé après
la métaphore du moins Président je ne
ferai pas comme l'AgitéE d'avant on a eu
droit à moi Président j'ai découvert
Castorama
fameuse allégorie de la boîte à outils
après le plombier polonais le tourner un
freezer
si c'est pas de la déchéance quand même
Chirac s'inspirait de Gaulle Mitterrand
de Mendes Hollande de Super Mario
alors seule grande mesure le choc de
simplification la fusion de la justice
et de l'intérieur et sa mise en ligne
sous le nom Mediapart
quand on pense que c'est médias partent
qui vient de lancer la réforme de la
fonction publique
c'est quand même dingue franchement
c'est trois journalistes web du centre
de Paris arrivent à faire le boulot du
ministère de l'intérieur des finances et
de la justice réunit enfin tu imagines
le potentiel d'économie quoi c'est c'est
[Applaudissements]
tout vous allez vous [ __ ] les
fonctionnaires dans la rue et puis les
intermittents qui rêvent d'avoir le site
de Morandini pour ministère de la
culture c'est le prochain truc et bon au
fond il fallait s'y attendre c'est pas
très étonnant je veux dire
historiquement c'est souvent des
moustachus qui ont fait radicalement
bouger des choses
[Applaudissements]
je pense au brigade du tigre
capitale alors toute cette affaire de
boîte à outils vite éclipsé par des
problèmes d'argent et c'est accusation
indigne Cahuzac aurait un compte en
Suisse ah non c'est à Singapour
alors je précise la plaine moi je suis
Suisse et j'ai un compte en France et je
fais déjà l'objet d'une enquête en
Suisse mais pas de la part des services
fiscaux mais des services psychiatriques
je dis ça de payer mes impôts ici parce
que je trouve ça formidable je pense
c'est super important de participer à
l'effort de redressement dans la justice
dans l'égalité du mariage pour tous we
are the world we are the childing et
parce que attention excusez-moi mais
d'être un peu engagé mais c'est vrai que
l'impôt ça sert à payer des hôpitaux des
crèches des écoles mais aussi des trucs
bien comme les prisons les charters la
bombe nucléaire des CRS qui viennent à
Notre-Dame-des-Landes bastonner des punk
à chien
non j'adore payer les impôts c'est
délicieux tu sais ce quand tu ouvres
l'enveloppe du Trésor et que tu as cette
belle odeur si typique de
l'administration française qui vous
saisissent ce mélange d'encre de
photocopieuses de moquette et de pucelle
cadrage génère
ah les femmes de l'administration c'est
les seuls qui arrivent à cumuler acné et
ménopause
puis une fois l'enveloppe ouverte on
détache le type on voit le montant et
comme tout le monde on ajoute un zéro
pour le pourboire de Mosco ici
alors Cahuzac a laissé une lettre dans
laquelle il se dit dévasté par le
remords alors c'est sûr s'il avait placé
un peu plus de fréquence Suisse
peut-être pas eu besoin de rester en
France
alors François Hollande a réagi le
président de la République prend acte
avec grande sévérité des aveux de Jérôme
Cahuzac tout de suite ça calme quoi moi
je sens que tous les ministres vont
fermer leur livret A
il y a ce petit truc qui paraît que
Cahuzac était en soupçonnable
un chirurgien esthétique directeur de
clinique privée qui a une société de
conseils pour l'industrie pharmaceutique
et qui prend sa carte au PS dire comme
un disque de suspicion il faut quoi en
plus
et Hollande qui dit qu'ils savaient pas
qu'ils pensaient que tout le monde était
propre ça c'est vraiment le truc c'est
moi candide de la République au lieu de
lire Jojo Lapin et le Club des Cinq je
ferais mieux de relire Les Misérables
en toute la question maintenant c'est
quel avenir pour Jérôme non mais c'est
vrai avec un nom pareil tu diras parce
recycler dans les eaux minérales elle
prend sa source en Suisse enrichie aux
éléments pompé à Singapour et qu'elle
s'appelle Oreo Cahuzac
c'est un peu agaçant comme le retour de
la morale et de la transparence moi je
veux pas être désagréable mais si tous
les hommes politiques sont pur et
irréprochables il y a forcément une
partie de la population qui va pas se
sentir représentée
cyclisme Hidalgo talonné par BMX ah non
pardon Mkm
alors ces deux styles très différents
c'est une jolie bataille c'est très dans
vraiment entre le jeu de domination
entre la blonde diaphane bobo à
chevalière et la brune latino caliente
façon jello cuire latex boule de geisha
commerce équitable
ça va être du propre pour nourrir les
fantasmes plus fort qu'un club sm laisse
bien opter pour une séance au Conseil de
Paris
je sais pas pour faire une polémique
mais il paraît que vous êtes à la
retraite depuis 2011 ça fait polémique
mais moi je vous comprends quoi c'est
mérité vous avez quand même lancé le
vélib pari plage les couloirs de bus
enfin le baron Haussmann à côté c'est
Stéphane Plaza
[Applaudissements]
football la presse félicite le PSG pour
son match nul face au Barça comme quoi
bien encadré peut encore fournir de
beaux spectacles l'immigration
certains ne cautionneront pas mais c'est
pas grave made in France le créateur du
ciré jaune est décédé mais le créateur
de la mouette qui chie court toujours
Tunisie incarcéré pour sodomie c'est
quand même sympa la justice tunisienne
quoi on condamne un type pour un acte
auquel il pourra s'adonner librement en
prison
une bonne nouvelle peut-être oui Cécile
Duflot est né un 1er avril
donc si ça se trouve elle est vraiment
fictive alors
pas belle la vie
[Musique]
quoi de neuf
plus que 10490 jours avant le retour de
Sarko à l'Élysée
alors Hollande est revenu faire son
stand-up tu vois le l'Élysée Comedy Club
un micro un pupitre plafond à moulure et
boum je vanne
encore fait une stand-up sur l'autorité
moi Président vous connaissez par Raoul
le truc lui qui fait un skull sur
l'autorité autant de crédibilité que
voir Boutin interpréter le lâcher de
[ __ ]
il y a une semaine il parlait d'un choc
de simplification et là il décide de
créer une autorité de surveillance
Hollande créateur de Haute Autorité
depuis 2012 c'est le truc c'est quoi ce
terme de Haute Autorité je veux dire
quand tu penses qu'il existe une autre
autorité c'est que tu crois qu'il existe
aussi une base autorité c'est surtout
donc que tu connais rien en autorité
vous savez ce que c'est c'est un mec qui
bloque l'entrée du ministère de la
défense avec un Vélib c'est Hollande qui
fait une tentative de [ __ ]
[Applaudissements]
il paraît que les grands leaders se
révèlent dans la crise quand on voit le
mal qui se donne pour gérer une histoire
de RIB quand même alors
inutile de le dire qui n'a pas mentionné
héros pauvre Jean-Marc héros qui a porté
son soutien à Borlo qui a demandé une
commission d'enquête sur l'action du
gouvernement durant l'affaire Cahuzac
j'ai jamais vu c'est le premier ministre
qui est d'accord de faire une commission
pour être au courant de ce qui se passe
sous sa responsabilité
alors opération transparence tout le
monde à poil moi franchement j'aurais
préféré rien savoir vraiment Fillon qui
a une bicoque dans la Sarthe du flow une
twingo à 1500 euros Belkacem un livret A
Filippetti un appartement de 70 mètres
carrés on demande au ministre de
l'honnêteté pas de faire pitié
[Applaudissements]
mais ça ça c'est ça c'est cette idée
grandiose du plus tes pauvre plus c'est
bien vu quoi c'est un truc la France
avec le seul pays au monde où on est
fier de gagner le SMIC de rouler encore
goût et de bouffer au Flunch
non mais si on continue comme ça même
les Roms voudront plus venir
puis ce truc de transparence certains ça
va les [ __ ] mal ça va il y a déjà des
rumeurs sur Fabius quoi pareil qu'il est
en train de vendre ses tableaux pour
acheter un stock de Kangoo
c'est l'image quoi c'est l'image en tout
cas avec tous ces histoires patrimoine
on sait au moins une chose moscoviscine
ça avait rien sur Cahuzac il a aucun
flair ce type j'ai regardé son
patrimoine le type il a un duplex à
Montbéliard
la seule façon de faire une plus-value
là-bas c'est s'il y a une montée du
niveau de la mer de 15 mètres
amour et va joli appel à manifester avec
Mélenchon le 5 mai prochain il fallait
bien qu'ils se rencontrent les deux quoi
ça pouvait que connecter quoi c'est la
comédie romantique trop de skis de
l'année ou quand Robespierre rencontre
lenacha au sheesku c'est après Hiroshima
mon amour le goulag dure trois ans Lady
Paul pot
ou l'histoire du Scandinave qui a la
ménopause découvre en même temps
l'orgasme et la langue française
[Musique]
parlante cinéma cinéma engagé Véronique
Genest déclare dans le Figaro pourquoi
j'arrête Julie Lescaut mais oui pourquoi
pour une fois qu'on avait une série
policière qui rivalisait avec les
meilleurs productions ouzbek
tourisme alors je sais pas tout le monde
a vu cette photo de kim Jong-Un Mahjong
2 ou backgammon 3 je sais plus très bien
mais qu'il est fort faire croire au
monde entier qui va lancer une attaque
nucléaire alors qu'il fait du cheval en
Camargue
c'est franchement c'est pas avec cette
photo qui fera trembler le monde enfin
on dirait Attila avec des problèmes de
cholestérol c'est pas
moi je fais de la peine moi Kung Fu
Panda c'est
paumé parmi ces généraux là on dirait un
petit obèse kidnappé par une maison de
retraite du 13e arrondissement
métaphysique des liquides il paraît que
Cahuzac était franc-maçon ah oui alors
le nom de saloche c'est Locarno 28 c'est
une ville suisse il est fort pour
brouiller les pistes lui c'est un truc
dans les gens évidemment vont se dire
mais c'est quoi un franc-maçon alors
informations comment dire c'est trop
snoke pour être catho pas assez select
pour être juif
moi je réfléchis
Margaret Thatcher est morte
Thatcher on peut dire ce qu'on veut je
dirais peut-être pas fait beaucoup pour
les mineurs mais sans elle on aurait
sans doute jamais connu les clashs et
les Sex Pistols
alors Jean-Luc Mélenchon estime que
Margaret Thatcher va découvrir en enfer
ce qu'elle a fait au mineur
vu le poids politique du Front de Gauche
c'est surtout Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui
découvrira en enfer ce qui n'a pas fait
pour les mineurs
[Applaudissements]
moi je me méfie quoi un athée qui croit
à l'enfer mais ça c'est le problème des
laïc enragés quoi sont tellement sûrs
que Dieu n'existe pas qui s'estime
légitime pour prendre sa place c'est un
truc
les journaux évidemment se demandent si
il faudrait une Margaret Thatcher en
France ce serait chouette
ah non mais elle a Florange au lieu de
vous proposer à reclassement elle se
serait arrangé pour vous filer la
nationalité indienne
[Rires]
t'aura pas ton agreg un jeu de mots
alors le grand rabbin de France Gilbert
Heim déjà coupable de plagiat en plus
usurpé son agreg de philo c'est un
manque plus qu'on découvre qu'il
organisait des soirées jambon rillettes
avec Tariq Ramadan
[Applaudissements]
Larousse définition du mot mariage a été
modifié c'est plus l'union de deux
personnes de sexe opposées mais l'union
de deux personnes de sexe opposées ou de
même sexe blabla etc c'est faux faut
tout réécrire mariage acte précédant le
divorce et dont le but est de faire une
jolie fête lorsque tout le monde se
supporte encore
c'est c'est pas le seul terme à réécrire
et on a d'autres comme filiation acte
qui permet de retrouver le connard ou la
[ __ ] à qui on a rien demandé
adoption coup de pouce du destin qui
permet à certains gosses de tomber sur
des parents plus compétents que ce livre
est d'origine
après une nuance enfant adoptée
vietnamien enfant très prisé par la
bourgeoisie du 16e arrondissement du
fait de la ressemblance physique qu'il
développe avec la mère adoptive une fois
qu'elle a passé ses premiers liftings
[Applaudissements]
alors peut-être une bonne nouvelle pour
terminer c'est Pierre Berger veut des
préservatifs gratuits au collège comme
si les profs n'avaient pas les moyens de
s'en acheter
pas belle la vie
[Applaudissements]
tout va bien tout va bien le chômage
diminue le pays tient un cap Charisma
croissance à tous les étages c'est bref
cette semaine donc j'aurais parlé les
patrimoines ont été publiés moi je me
suis précipité j'ai allumé l'ordi
cliquez sur la page baisser mon froc
attrapé mon sopalin
consternation consternation je cherchais
le youporn du patrimoine je suis tombé
sur Leboncoin.fr tu vois à côté Louis la
Brocante c'est un magasin Hermès c'est
un truc
bon il y a des motifs de soulagement
j'ai plus de blagues Benoît Hamon
Benoît Hamon tout le monde voit c'est la
fashion victime qui se tire la bourre
vestimentaire avec Manuel Valls
à mon tu le croises avec un sac Tati tu
lui dis alors beau gosse c'est la gloire
à mon non mais je le plains quoi le mec
il a une opel corsa à 4600 euros quoi il
doit pas être évident pour emballer à la
sortie de chez Castel
évidemment aucun ministre n'a un compte
en Suisse tu m'étonnes quoi vu les
sommes qu'ils annoncent à part Fabius et
Delaunay quand tu es banquier en Suisse
t'as pas envie d'avoir des clients qui
gagnent moins que ta secrétaire c'est
inutile de dire qu'il y en a pas un qui
possède des actions en investissement
dans une boîte mais ça c'est l'ennemi
cela finance tout ça le vieux logiciel
socialiste c'est comme ça c'est quoi
faut plus de crèche d'école et
d'hôpitaux c'est vraiment génial quoi
que des endroits qui te rappelle que tu
es pas autonome c'est un peu truc c'est
en gros c'est à 40 ans tu as pas une
Rolex c'est que tu es peut-être membre
du gouvernement
j'ai trouvé des incohérences dans les
déclarations j'ai regardé
Geneviève fiorazo qui déclare une twingo
à 8000 euros sans déconner ça existe
c'est Twingo à 8000 euros franchement à
moins d'avoir 20 g de coupe dans la
boîte à gants je vois pas trop comment
c'est possible
[Applaudissements]
alors
elle est pas la seule à avoir des trucs
un peu il y a Belkacem qui a un scooter
d'une valeur de 500 €, elle l'a acheté à
la sortie du métro de Barbès
tu sais le truc ticket Marlboro Piaggio
après 20 ans de politique je crois que
vous en avez parlé aussi Moscovici
possède un patrimoine de 3000 euros de
plus que Cécile Duflot non mais si c'est
du flot et le pire c'est qu'il a deux
fois moins de pognon que le ministre de
la Culture le ministre de l'Économie
moins riche que le ministre de la
culture c'est comme si Serge Dassault
gagne moins que le premier secrétaire de
la CGT
moi je comprends Cahuzac a quitté le
gouvernement avant la publication parce
que pas mêlés son patrimoine à celui des
autres en termes de glamour Cahuzac au
milieu de ce gouvernement c'est c'est
comme garer une Bentley sur le parking
de la chaussure
le pauvre le pauvre c'est-à-dire en plus
il a dû se taper cette confession à la
télé et le mec tout compris penaud c'est
comme s'il avait filé les plans de la
ligne Maginot à Merkel
alors héros qui en profite pour faire sa
sortie du moment il a dit qu'il a trouvé
l'interview pathétique
Jean-Marc quand on est premier ministre
de la cinquième puissance mondiale et
qu'on déclare un combi folkswagen à 1000
euros on a la décence de la fermer
[Applaudissements]
il a rajouté quelque chose vraiment de
savoureux ma part d'ombre c'est mon
combi il faut Volkswagen
ah bon sous la banquette arrière il y a
quoi Xavier de Ligonnès
alors évidemment la question que peut
faire Hollande à l'Élysée que peut faire
René côté notre bien-aimé
je sais pas moi condamner les fenêtres
construire des meurtrières faire
bouillir de l'huile
commander une perruque à uzac se [ __ ]
des implants mammaires préparer la fuite
quoi tu vois au rythme où ça va c'est
pas Bernard Arnault qu'on va choper à la
frontière belge c'est Hollande
économie Petro plus ferme on aura finira
plus de pétrole en Normandie en même
temps est-ce qu'on affine des camemberts
au Qatar
sport
deux explosions à l'arrivée du marathon
de Boston moi je comprends moi je
comprends moi les gens qui mettent plus
de 4 heures à Marathon ça me saoule
non mais le vrai problème avec tout ça
non mais il y a un problème c'est un
problème de fond pour réfléchir faut
s'engager dire on sait pas qui a gagné
la course
enfin si c'est Al-Qaïda je veux dire
passer de 3000 morts le 11 septembre
2001 à 3 morts 12 ans plus tard c'est à
croire que Al-Qaïda intégré la zone euro
nécrologie
Margaret Thatcher a été enterré alors ça
a coûté 12 millions d'euros alors
attention la famille à payer la
crémation les fleurs le transport en
fait les 12 millions c'est les mesures
de sécurité
la sécurité
elle est morte
préparer un attentat sur une personne
décédée c'est un concept
journalisme Justine Bieber a visité la
maison d'Anne Frank jusque-là pourquoi
pas et dans le livre d'or il a écrit
Anne était une fille formidable elle
aurait sans doute été fan de moi c'est
dur à dire enfin en revanche s'il avait
écrit ça dans le livre d'ordre de la
maison de Marc Dutroux
tu vois ce que je veux dire c'est super
ça là mais c'est pour ça qu'on paye
mariage alors l'UMP déclare que si elle
arrive au pouvoir elle ne va pas abroger
la loi sur le mariage mais la modifier
c'est comme les 35 heures ça c'est vous
reprochez à Hollande de faire du Sarkozy
au pouvoir alors que vous faites du
Hollande dans l'opposition
franchement l'UMP c'est pas des flèches
le jour où vous arriverez à [ __ ]
autant de personnes dans la rue pour
manifester contre la dépense publique
que vous arrivez en mettre pour
protester contre la possibilité d'offrir
un cadre légal à une sodomie on prendra
peut-être au sérieux
tourisme le roi de l'évasion Redouane
Faïd s'est fait la belle il était
enfermé à Lille bon on comprend ça
décuple la motivation quoi tu as envie
de on l'aurait enfermé à Fort-de-France
illustré encore que c'est
un flingue des explosifs il a tenu en
joue 4matons avant de prendre la fuite
en France s'échapper d'une prison c'est
plus simple que de rentrer en boîte
justice ouverture du procès de
Jean-Claude Mas l'ex droit des prothèses
mammaires frauduleuses 300 à 400 femmes
sont venues assister au procès quoi dès
qu'il s'agit de coquetterie quand il y a
tout le monde c'est pas au procès de
clause Barbie qu'on aurait vu une telle
concentration
alors elles sont là à chouineo il est
indifférent il s'en fout d'où le méchant
il fait qu'il fasse quoi qu'il arrive
rigolard salut les prothèses qui fument
bien sûr je suis coupable j'ai mis du
mazout mais au prix du brut j'allais pas
mettre du kérosène
bonne nouvelle
on a découvert un autoportrait de
Baudelaire
ah non non ça c'est pas non ça c'est
autre chose c'est autre alors on précise
que les clichés n'ont pas été retouchés
c'est dur même Photoshop vous voulez pas
d'elle alors pas belle la vie
[Applaudissements]
dictons à l'affiche du jour en avril ne
te découvre pas d'un fil en mai porte la
burqa s'il te plaît
alors oui il y a une chose qui a Claude
Bartholin qui a reçu des menaces
adressées aux présidents de la Douma de
la République socialiste et soviétique
je tiens à dire que ce n'est pas de moi
même si je compte bien entendu porter
plainte pour plagir
mariage gay toujours alors tu connais la
dernière blague de c'est un député qui
fait les marchés le dimanche et il dit
aux gens mais vous savez on fait
vraiment tout pour lutter contre le
chômage et tout et les lecteurs qui
répond
occupez-vous plutôt du mariage gay
[Applaudissements]
donc la France c'est le 14e pays au
monde a adopter le mariage gay ce qui
signifie quand même que de son pays ne
l'ont pas adopté c'est cool on va enfin
pouvoir être de gauche et traiter le
tiers-monde derrière et
alors ça a conduit à l'expression d'une
certaine rancoeur je veux dire c'est le
printemps des groupuscules d'extrême
droite paraît-il enfin au lieu de les
stigmatiser il serait peut-être temps de
leur dire la vérité on sait bien que Eva
Braun c'était pour la galerie
si le mariage gay existait en 40 Adolf
et Rudolf serait sans doute les
grands-pères comblés d'un petit Galliano
[Applaudissements]
frigide Barjot insulter c'est vrai
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé et la coucher avec un Bosch
enfin c'est
c'était très violent c'était vrai moi je
pensais qu'ils allaient la tondre cela
dit c'est une comparaison un peu
malheureuse enfin si à la Libération
tous les collabos étaient fait-on par
des gaz aurait sans doute eu un peu plus
de style
je me disais j'ai une question enfin si
la droite revient au pouvoir et qu'elle
approche la loi les couples qui seront
passés entre les gouttes et qui aura
adopté les gamins seront considérés
comme des collectors
exactement
on va les retrouver sur ebay vent gamin
d'occasion prêt abolition mariage gay
sans esthétique prémâché œdipe à l'état
neuf
truc c'est que ma copine veut adopter en
ce moment et moi j'ai dit oui à
condition que l'enfant vienne d'un
couple gay c'est beau c'est beaucoup
plus simple je veux dire au gamin je
pourrais toujours lui dire si tu savais
d'où tu venais tu la fermerais un peu
[Applaudissements]
mais moi ce qui me gêne avec cette loi
c'est c'est qu'elle n'ouvre pas de
nouveau droit aux hétérosexuels
mots je veux accéder à une sexualité où
on n'a pas besoin de se préoccuper de la
contraception puisque les homos peuvent
avoir des gosses sans faire l'amour je
revendique le droit de ne pas en avoir
en le faisant
égalité égalité égalité pour dire la
vérité moi je trouve c'est manif assez
belle quoi pour une fois que les gens de
manifestent pas pour des questions de
fric c'est quand même tu vois pas la
droite manifeste pour des Hakim
métaphysique la gauche pour des
accumatériels chacun se bat pour ce qui
lui manque
de toute façon cette histoire faut être
clair un enfant n'a pas besoin d'un papa
et d'une maman non il a besoin de deux
adultes
donc de papa
international attentat contre
l'ambassade de France en Libye alors il
commence à s'internationaliser les
Corses sans prendre à la résidences
d'été de BHL
s'il vous plaît
[Applaudissements]
Boston alors on a retrouvé les auteurs
c'est Joker ternayev l'inventeur du
triathlon moderne
on commence par un marathon on continue
par une traque en voiture on termine
dans un bateau
dans le type il a terminé dans un sale
étage il cligne des yeux pour donner ses
réponses tellement il est abîmé après le
Scaphandre et le papillon l'intubé et le
kebab
alors il paraît que c'est la faute de
son frère le frère s'est radicalisé au
d'agostan tu m'étonnes rien que le nom
du pays tu sais qu'il va pas revenir
avec des cheveux longs et les lunettes à
la John Lennon
football le Bayern écrase le Barça
Dortmund écrase le Real la finale aura
lieu à Wembley pour une fois que les
Allemands vont atterrir en Angleterre
[Applaudissements]
certes les Allemands ont moins de
chômage plus de croissance mais est-ce
qu'on peut vraiment admirer un peuple
qui dolâtre Franck Ribéry
culture un tribunal a décidé que les
participants de l'île de la tentation ne
seront pas des artistes interprètes ah
bon donc les conneries qui racontent
c'est vraiment eux
c'est tout le génie des participants de
la téléréalité engagés des frais
d'avocat pour faire reconnaître par un
tribunal qui sont fondamentalement
débiles
justice le Syndicat de la magistrature a
un mur des cons
ça c'est un peu le Facebook à la
française tout ça alors sur ce mur sur
afficher des photos de personnalité
essentiellement droite bon le syndicat
se défendu en disant les blagues des uns
n'engagent pas les décisions des autres
c'est vrai en dehors des murs du
tribunal les juges de nurinaires étaient
très connus pour leur humour antisémite
bonne nouvelle non plutôt un message
santé dans le Vaucluse il y a un père de
famille qui a coupé le sexe de son
enfant
boire aux circoncir il faut choisir
alors ma belle la vie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
en résumé un an pourquoi faire pourquoi
faire des réformes sociétales bon c'est
chic en fait les Français n'ont pas élu
un gouvernement mais la rédaction de
Marie-Claire
avec l'été qui approche je sens arriver
le plan anti-obésité et la rubrique
mycose des plages
Hollande se débat il lutte il est là je
l'ai vu dans un collège il disait on
s'est moqué de ma boîte à outils mais
quand vous tombez en panne mieux vaut
avoir des outils que rien du tout oui en
même temps si on peut éviter de rouler
en Peugeot
alors il y a ce mec de PSA qui n'ont
rien compris ah le jour de la fermeture
les actionnaires se votent un dividende
bah c'est pour ça qu'ils l'ont fermé du
con
ils vont quand même pas fermer une usine
pour distribuer des tickets de
rationnement enfin un moment
fatiguant ce pays je peux plus alors il
y a un défilé intéressant quand même le
Front National qui enfin intéressant
rien d'intéressant à dire sauf qu'une
militante du FN accroché un saucisson au
drapeau pour établir un périmètre de
sécurité c'est
au moins on a une idée de la politique
de défense si le FN arrive au pouvoir le
premier fournisseur de l'armée ça serait
plus d'assaut mais qu'au chelou
alors il y a cette idée très lumineuse
que l'immigration et la source de tous
nos problèmes non c'est peut-être une
vraie solution pour la France enfin le
gouvernement serait quand même vachement
plus capable si avec des Allemands
Europe le PS critique Merkel alors
critiquer Merkel pourquoi pas mais
est-ce très prudent en même temps de
baisser le budget de la défense
enfin je sais pas mais Alena le
programme d'histoire il s'arrête tout au
sacre de Clovis
diplomatie Hollande a fait un voyage en
Chine alors il a parlé des droits de
l'homme c'est super idée c'est lumineux
ça aussi
inutile de dire que lorsqu'il est rentré
au Tibet on fêté l'indépendance c'est
une blague la Chine c'est vachement bien
c'est quand même ce beau pays qui prouve
que pour fonctionner le capitalisme n'a
pas du tout besoin de démocratie
économie on continue de tuer les talents
dans ce pays ça c'est devenu l'histoire
de ce type la formidable géant oh là là
le type il arrive à vendre 500000 euros
des tableaux qui va le 20.000 on lui
colle un juge au cul
pour une fois qu'un fonctionnaire a le
sens des affaires et
au lieu de l'emmerder on ferait mieux de
le nommer VRP à Dassault avant de des
rafales je sais pas le rendre utile quoi
compétitivité toujours place Stalingrad
à SDF fouille dans une poubelle et
trouve des armes bon jusque là belle
histoire
avec ça le type il fait quoi il fait
quoi je vous le demande madame la
ministre qu'est-ce qu'il fait il appelle
les flics
vous savez ce que ça vaut des arbres au
marché noir tu m'étonnes qu'il est à la
rue quoi
les SDF faut pas leur donner des
logements madame mais une connexion à
leboncoin il faut leur apprendre
carton un gamin de 5 ans à basse sa
soeur de deux ans avec son fusil je suis
très choqué pourtant le type il avait un
papa et une maman
donc je suis une famille équilibrée
alors selon le médecin légiste il s'agit
d'un accident heureusement qu'il
convoque un médecin légiste pour ça quoi
sinon Al-Qaïda serait capable de
revendiquer le truc aujourd'hui
médecine un gynéco accusé de viol et
radié de l'ordre des médecins c'est quoi
un viol pour un gynéco c'est un frottis
agrémenté d'insultes
économie la France me favoriser
l'immigration étudiantes c'est vrai
quand on voit les résultats à Boston ça
donne des idées
en fait Erasmus c'est le nom occidental
d'Al-Qaïda tu es un petit programme
d'échange d'idées de culture enfin
Montebourg se réjouit peut-être que
l'arrivée d'étudiants tchétchène ça va
relancer les cocottes Moulinex
zoophilie Booba publie une sextape
mettant en scène La Fouine
t'es un ours qui matte la sexualité
d'une fouine en fait le 9 3 c'est un
parc naturel
bon cinéma Horse Tappert
tout ça c'est quand même un choc c'est
comme apprendre que Véronique Genest se
réussit la homophobe
c'est quand même moi ça me pose un
problème éthique si toutes ces années
j'ai préféré Derrick à Navarro est-ce
que ça fait de moi un navire au poulet
ludique un député suédois veut obliger
les hommes à uriner assis un nom
vivement qu'on oblige les handicapés à
pisser debout
[Musique]
sport le basketteur NBA Jason Collins a
déclaré je suis noir et je suis gay ça a
quand même dû être un choc pour ses
coéquipiers d'apprendre qu'il était noir
générosité Toulouse poignardée pour une
cigarette refusée il y a vraiment plus
de valeur mourir pour avoir voulu
préserver la santé de son agresseur
alors faut peut-être terminer par une
bonne nouvelle parce que des choses
positives Bernard Tapie déclare je suis
prêt à aider Hollande cool enfin quoi en
général quand tapis vient à ton secours
c'est que tu vas bientôt faire faillite
et qui va te racheter
alors pas belle la vie
[Musique]
vraiment désolé on m'a posé une
thématique cette semaine on demande de
faire le bilan d'une année de
quinquennat je comprends pas très bien
le type il a 24 % d'opinions positives
je passais plus un bilan c'est une
liquidation judiciaire
il y a un an il était à 55% le type il
perd 33% par an il est un type qui se
prend une mine antipersonnel il suffit
de moins vite quoi
pour avoir encore une opinion positive
en 2017 la sofraisse va être obligée de
sonder les Maliens
mais bon il y en a assez de mes
atermoiements d'un broyeur réa qu'on
souhaite que je me rattrape que je lui
traite des lauriers pour les 1 an du
quinquennat des lauriers des lauriers
avec son art de procès personne sera
plutôt des bouquet garni le truc enfin
bref allez
Aude au chef bien-aimé
il y a donc un an le Messie au pouvoir
arrive à mais d'où vient-il
la légende raconte qu'il a été recueilli
par un conseiller général alors qu'il se
trouvait dans un panier en osier qui est
dérivé sur la tulle
bref Guy constatant le mollet du
bonhomme s'exclamera tu seras pédalo mon
fils
la loi sur le mariage gate et
alors bien sûr je rappelle le
téléspeleteur qu'est-ce que la tulle
qu'est-ce que la tue alors c'est une
sorte de Nil qui traverse la Corrèze et
dont la crue gorge régulièrement de
l'immont fertile les terrains de rugby
espace essentiel à la vie du Sud-Ouest
où les jeunes gamins se jettent sur des
ballons en forme de suppositoire pour
signifier leur sortie de l'enfance
55 ans plus tard mai 2012 l'enfant est
devenu roi après 10 ans de sous
bonapartisme l'alliance des nains des
gays des hobbits chassent le vol Sarko
du Palais de l'Élysée
la France respire à nouveau c'est la
liesse place de la Bastille à nouveau
des drapeaux algériens flottent
colonisez-nous semble crier la foule
joyeusement bigarrée au son des tam-tam
breton et des yoyo alsaciens
quoi de plus naturel pour cette joyeuse
troupe que de se retrouver sur l'endroit
où furent construites les Baumettes des
rois de France
[Musique]
serein est confiant le merveilleux
régent lancent son programme intitulé Le
Yaka
à ne pas confondre avec le haka c'est
une manière pudique d'aller à la selle
deux minutes avant le coup d'envoi d'un
match de rugby
[Musique]
sur l'estrade l'amour reprend sa place
love comme bac
la compagne du Cher valoche surnommé
Samsonite première pour les intimes se
précipite sur lui pour l'embrasser de
force un geste qui dit tout du génie
diplomatique de l'homme oui français
détenu à l'étranger moi aussi je suis un
otage
[Rires]
comme le veut l'histoire entre la France
et sa première dame c'est le coup de
foudre en une apparition
et ceci sans avoir pondu le moindre
album
pareil pour la guerre notre de Gaulle 4G
forme un gouvernement de combat chez lui
nous venu l'ouverture pourquoi aller
piocher dans l'opposition les
incompétents qu'on possède chez soi
mais soucieux de ménager les agences de
notation et l'adresse un premier signe
d'apaisement monde de la finance il
nomme un gouvernement de stagiaires
de mémoire du Sillé jamais à l'Elysée
les photocopies ont été aussi belles
entre les ministres la concorder règne
mais après tout que pourraient opposer
du flot allongé sans sucre à Najat
double crème ou Jean-Marc postit à
stabiloval
les ministres plongent dans le travail
ils n'ont plus à se soucier de leur
avenir avec l'expérience accumulée ils
pourront toujours rebondir chez
Starbucks
[Musique]
juin le gouvernement est au travail
porté par l'énergie sans limite de
Jean-Marc Ayrault c'est alors de meneurs
se révèlent redoutable dans les couloirs
les anecdotes sont à l'image de l'homme
tu as pris de la coque non j'ai vu
Jean-Marc
enfin
[Applaudissements]
Jean-Marc premier mime de France
le handicap est représenté au plus haut
sommet de l'État plus besoin de faire
des dons Téléthon les impôts s'en charge
septembre octobre
requinquer les Français retrouvent leur
travail favoris c'est-à-dire sa
recherche
novembre décembre le changement
écologique se profile pour diminuer la
pollution automobile en supprime sa
source c'est à dire les usines que les
produits
dans le même élan on décrète Lorraine
réserve naturelle Florence et
débarrassée enfin de ses fourneaux et
aux ouvriers ingrats ont proposé une
reconversion dans les métiers du futur
les locaux de formation sont prêts la
mairie n'attend plus que la livraison
des militaires
tous les ministres sont mis à
contribution à Val ce qui est chargé de
reconduire les Roms dans leur écosystème
naturel au petit rhum le rhum qui a muté
génétiquement il semble s'épanouir aussi
bien sur les boulevards parisiens que
sur les champs-émis Soirat s'il vous
plaît
janvier février
enfin le droit de vote des étrangers est
accepté oh oui Seigneur les électeurs
Allemands sont d'accord pour nous
accorder un an délai supplémentaire pour
réduire les déficits mais sans relance
le déficit n'est rien
par bonheur l'excellent monde bourré aux
manettes
sur le mode des industries de pointe qui
ont fait la renommée de l'Angleterre
victorienne il pressant l'avenir c'est
le tricot les gars
mais pour vendre des marinières faut des
acheteurs alors on lance le mariage gay
c'est un sujet qui passionne et qui
rassemble comme jamais oh certes un
petit groupe muscul de punk monogame
fait la claque mais le pays est-il assez
stupide pour suivre ces gens qui
prétendent qu'un enfant a besoin d'un
père et d'une mère pourquoi pas la
fidélité durant le mariage
[Musique]
dans la foulée le beau Hollande obtient
sa première grande victoire contre la
finance internationale après des mois de
lutte il obtient enfin la démission de
Cahuzac
mais un an après son élection le pays
était sur une bonne pente
une seule crainte entre les ministres
avec notre talent et si on se faisait
débaucher par le gouvernement grec
hélas tout ce qui est beau passe trop
vite il ne reste plus que 4 ans alors
elle est pas belle la vie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bon bah bientôt juillet vous tirez vous
partez ce qui est où
[Musique]
alors je dis ça il faut réserver
maintenant parce que moi au ski je fais
partie des haussiens
j'aime pas les lire en juillet parce que
tu es sûr devoir mettre les chaînes quoi
c'est un truc moi j'adore parler de la
météo quoi la météo c'est quand même la
mondanité à la portée des ploucs quoi
c'est l'échange Ryanair ça c'est quand
un lien social minimal tu parles de la
prostate du voisin quand tu as aucun
lien tu parles de la prostate de Dieu
c'est
mariage premier mariage gay a été
célébré mercredi bon pourquoi pas en
tout cas moi je serais gay ce qui arrive
ce qui arrive pas d'arriver moi je
déteste Coldplay mais
moi je serais gai au mariage je
demanderai d'être considéré comme
l'épouse bah ouais comme ça en cas de
divorce tu es sûr d'avoir la garde des
enfants
non parce qu'avec deux paires qui se
séparent ce sera forcément une garde
partagée résultat les gamins vont être
en permanence tiraillés entre deux
foyers donc le mariage homosexuel crée
des enfants instables CQFD
alcool qu'un rapport un mec qui a
dépensé 42000 euros en boîte en
Champagne avec la carte de crédit de son
père
il serait temps qu'il se calme le fils
Fabius
ça devait être le fils de Jean Vincent
placé
alors vous allez me dire ouais non mais
il est coréen coréen
[Musique]
comme si ça changeait quelque chose
radicalité mais au mécène alors
l'agresseur du militaire à la défense a
été retrouvé grâce à son pass Navigo
forcément un terroriste qui frotte pas
la RATP les gens sont surpris quoi
et bon c'est juste que techniquement
essaye de sauter au dessus d'un
tourniquet avec une djellaba
nouveautés le type s'appelle Alexandre
n'est pas habitué Alexandre alors il a
cru que ça suffisait pour pas se faire
remarquer parce que son complice à lui
dire non mais tu vas pas y aller comme
ça tu vas te faire repérer avec ça mais
t'inquiète pas j'ai un nom français je
veux personnellement parce qu'en terme
de camouflage il a pas mis le paquet je
veux dire barbe djellaba calotte c'est
le bling bling fondamentaliste
le halal décomplexé hier le gars tu le
vois arriver de loin tu comprends que
c'est pas un Village People que c'est un
truc alors tout de suite des réactions
outrées c'est l'imam de Drancy si vous
trouvez que l'islam en France ne vous
convient pas allez vous en quitter la
France
animal c'est forcément très moderne
quand rien que le nom imam on dirait un
produit Apple quoi
c'est bon c'est pas raisonnable de dire
des trucs pareils quoi renvoyer tous les
intégristes chez eux enfin je rappelle
qu'on a qu'un seul porte-avion
puis la France tu l'aimes ou tu la
quittes c'est quand même un slogan à la
con quoi je veux dire comme si les
couples restaient ensemble parce qu'il
s'aimaient
[Rires]
pour un islamiste la France c'est comme
un plan cul l'ananas et la boivent des
mycoses elle au moins elle accueille
toute la misère du monde
je sais pas c'est une idée dans la
foulée on a arrêté aussi Redouane Faïd
en ce moment on valse il a un truc avec
l'Afrique du Nord
dans un mois il retrouve Faudel tu vois
c'est
Redouane Faïd a été arrêté dans un hôtel
de Pontault-Combault c'est vraiment la
déchéance c'est c'est comme Rambo qui
s'enfuit d'une prison vietnamienne et
qui se fait coffrer parce qu'il s'est
garé à une place réservée aux handicapés
c'est pareil
bref décès il nous a quitté ce grand
musicien qui a profondément marqué la
vie des français par son sens de la
ritournelle je veux parler de Jeff
Handman le guitariste de Slayer alors
Slayer c'est un groupe extraordinaire
c'est vraiment pas de la musique de
enfin pour tous quoi
[Rires]
on dirait Jennifer mais en train de se
faire violer
c'est
alors
faits divers
un homme qui se suicide dans une
maternelle bon je comprends déjà un
gosse qui chiale dans un TGV c'est dur
mais alors une classe
[Applaudissements]
évidemment on l'a fait tout un cirque à
le débrief psychologique des pauvres
petits choux c'est bon les gamins ils
sont dans une école du septième on les
traite comme s'il revenait d'une mission
à Kaboul non mais mon gosse il rentre à
la maison il a 5 ans il me dit ouais
papa à l'école il y a un monsieur qui
s'est tire une balle dans la tête moi je
lui répond j'espère que tu as aidé à
débarrasser
j'espère que tu as débarrassé au lieu de
rester planté là comme un con attendre
que Marcel Ruffo vienne te dire que si
tu nous emmerdes avec des cauchemars
pendant trois mois c'est parce qu'on a
pas su accueillir ta petite souffrance
de view occidentale sur gâté dont
l'imagination anorexique est incapable
d'envisager 30 secondes que le type
avait juste du coulis de tomates dans le
crâne qu'on va
[Applaudissements]
alors éducation le gouvernement va sévir
contre les tricheurs au bac
ah bon vu le niveau est encore besoin de
tricher
presse il paraît que Libé à moins de
100000 lecteurs selon la police ou selon
l'idée
les bras et des jambes c'est de quoi il
se plaint il s'embrasse sans pied s'il y
a bien une chose qu'on va plus regarder
c'est son cul
[Applaudissements]
football important de parler un peu de
sport il y a Créteil fait une croix sur
bagali Dabo
il y a toute une interview dans les
pages Ligue des Champions Île-de-France
alors bagali Dabo c'est un type super
prometteur quoi il rêve de jouer en
Ligue 1 et encore des mecs comme ça
quand on l'oublie trop souvent mais dans
ce pays il y a des footballeurs qui
rêvent juste de jouer à Montpellier ou à
Brest
alors bon bien sûr bon ça reste du foot
de seconde division quoi c'est
passionnant mais ça n'arrivera jamais à
la cheville du handball féminin quoi
c'est je sais pas si vous avez suivi le
match entre Fleury Loiret et Metz
le but de Pauline Baudouin
la balle dans le filet la balle elle
tombe le type il la ramasse quoi fallait
voir la salle quoi 15 personnes en
délire
cinéma
il y a une campagne actuellement
d'acteurs contre la surpêche
alors pour attirer l'attention on fait
poser des stars à poil à côté de poisson
et de mollusques ça c'est le grand truc
contemporain pour attirer l'attention
faut se [ __ ] et tu vois Mélanie
Laurent avec un tourteau pour dire il
faut arrêter de vider les réserves de la
mer
ah bon et elle elle fait quoi là le
crabe après la séance c'est quoi qu'on
va le ramener en taxi à l'île de Ré
peut-être
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et je me disais un truc en fait les
animaux ils sont tout le temps tout nus
oui la nature c'est d'une indécence
alors pas belle la vie elle est très
belle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous avez vu ce qui se passe en Turquie
c'est mort
ce qu'ils sont à 71 contre 61 il reste
un match à jouer contre Kassim pasa mais
comme Barry's basta vient de se prendre
un carton
[ __ ] d'arbitre quoi bon faut dire que
l'arbitrage était pas au niveau de ce
qu'on a vu en carabine sport et Besiktas
franchement mec
il ferait mieux de bosser dans baby-foot
quoi les mecs qui se cognent à faire des
sauts périlleux et lui il est joué
franchement vivement le retour sur les
terrains d'un mec intègre et compétent
comme augusen
[Rires]
vous attendiez que je vous parle de la
révolution de la plasturque la révolte
des 100 kebabs
le printemps salade oignon tomate un
chewing de harissa mais pas trop j'ai
des hémorroïdes quoi
international
[Applaudissements]
il paraît qu'ils utilisent aussi des gaz
en Syrie
ce qui veut dire que dans ce monde il y
a encore des manifs contre le mariage
pour tous
moi je comprends que la communauté
internationale hésite à intervenir c'est
vrai que les gars c'est pas très
dangereux on récupère assez vite je veux
dire aujourd'hui avec gambade Christine
Boutin
théorie de l'évolution féminité sport
Roland Garros l'endroit où les nageuses
et allemandes découvrent les activités
sur sol dur
le tennis moi tu sais moi je c'est un
sport de riche moi j'ai essayé ça coûte
une blinde quoi c'est entre
l'inscription dans un club l'achat du
matériel la location des types qui
viennent ramasser les balles
[Applaudissements]
alors votre traite on parle de réformer
le mode de calcul des retraites des
fonctionnaires oui parce que dans le
privé on calcule sa retraite sur 25 ans
dans le public c'est sur les six
derniers mois je vois pas ce qu'il y a
d'injuste pas comme si sur 25 ans a
fonctionnaire travailler plus que 6 mois
[Applaudissements]
allocation familiale on parle de les
diminuer pour les enfants c'est
dramatique pas à cause de ça dans de
nombreuses familles pauvres les parents
pourront plus acheter l'alcool pour
pouvoir les supporter
[Applaudissements]
alors
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît
l'intelligence est ici alors
les allocations j'ai vu ces 450 euros
par enfant quand tu penses qu'une
professionnelle touche deux fois plus
juste pour simuler leurs créations c'est
pas
famille toujours des familles Roms ont
été expulsées de l'île alors il vivait
le long des voies de chemin de fer c'est
un peu l'habitat à Rome c'est comme ça
c'est toujours très artificiailleur quoi
il y a un côté c'est l'annonce
immobilière typique des Roms c'est grand
espace de 400 m² à aménager selon
convenance parquet en terre battue dites
pointes de Bucarest proximité toute
commodité des charges bretelles
autoroute voit désaffecter animaux
domestiques acceptés chien chat
staphylocoque
médecine toujours
le nombre de médecins étrangers va
continuer à augmenter le patient va
enfin pouvoir reprendre le pouvoir sur
le médecin tu vois la question est-ce
que vous avez une carte Vitale on pourra
toujours répondre et vous vous avez
votre carte de séjour
bien sûr
la grande la grande question que se pose
tous les éditorialistes c'est est-ce
qu'ils seront capables de soigner les
mots franco-français la dépression la
détestation de soi le vote socialiste
beaucoup se forme en Roumanie c'est très
exigeant comme formation attention pour
des transplantations impressionnantes
les mecs ils savent remplacer un rein
par un moteur de Clio c'est très
médecine toujours Michael Douglas a
déclaré que son cancer de la gorge était
dû à une MST chopé à cause d'un
cunnilingus oui cunnilingus donnerait le
cancer de la gorge donc je profite de
cet espace j'ai une pensée émue pour
tous les canards de bain qu'il faudra
envoyer en chimiothérapie
[Applaudissements]
scientifiquement scientifiquement ça a
été prouvé c'est à dire que l'orgasme
féminin causé par voie buccale est
dangereux contrairement à l'orgasme
masculin qui est extrêmement simple
moi alors moi je dis ça c'est juste
c'est juste pour informer c'est pas du
tout pour même si c'est le devoir du
comics de s'engager sur les vrais sujets
lécher tu mets avaler préserve
[Applaudissements]
et tout ça ça a des effets il parait que
les différences de salaire dans un
couple ont des répercussions sur la vie
conjugale si la femme gagne plus le mec
a des problèmes d'érection il consomme
plus de viagra non scientifiquement je
commence à mieux comprendre les
relations franco-allemande
forcément quelque chose
[Applaudissements]
amour toujours
DSK aurait essayé d'embrasser une
journaliste italienne à la fin des
années 90 DS4 il est plus fort que la
drogue du violeur quoi avec lui les
victimes se réveillent 10 ans après quoi
plus que 5 ans et 1,5 pour mariage forcé
tu vois
municipale finalement NKM sera opposé à
Hidalgo bon selon Patrick Buisson NKM
serait à Paris la meilleure pour perdre
vu que dans le camp d'en face ils ont
mis la moins bonne pour gagner il a
peut-être ses chances
mais la vraie info
la vraie info c'est qu'en 2014 ce sera
forcément une femme qui sera maire de
Paris
hâte de voir la couleur du nouveau
papier peint dans le métro
non non c'est pas sexiste franchement
une femme ne peut pas ne peut pas gérer
une mairie elle ne peut pas non mais
si
elles n'ont aucune autorité qu'est-ce
qu'une femme sait faire dans une mairie
dire oui à son homme
c'est bien sûr
est-ce que ça s'est vu une grande ville
gérée par une femme enfin nulle part
dans le monde péchaouard qui recouvre
Kaboul Médine je vais faire un moment
faut être sérieux alors là vous dire
est-ce qu'il y a une bonne nouvelle
quand même cette semaine oui la vente de
poppers c'est à nouveau autorisé enfin
une conséquence bénéfique du mariage
pour tous qui ne profite pas qu'auguet
alors pas belle la vie
France le fascisme est à nos portes mort
de Clément Méric militant d'extrême
gauche c'est scandaleux jusqu'à scandale
l'agresseur Esteban d'origine espagnole
le chef des jeunesse nationalistes
révolutionnaire Serge Ayoub d'origine
libanaise Clément d'origine bretonne il
y en a marre de ce racisme antiselt
et puis sur enhérisson un
anticapitaliste qui meurt au cours d'une
vente privée
[Rires]
échec scolaire
Hollande va au Japon alors pourquoi pas
et la bague est-ce qu'il fait il
présente ses condoléances au chinois
[Applaudissements]
qu'inventer les racines chrétiennes de
l'Arabie Saoudite
et lire des extraits de Minecraft
il est en train de découvrir le monde ça
c'est au Japon il trouve formidable et
japonais en Allemagne ils trouvent
génial ce que font les Allemands c'est
l'extas permanente mais bon c'est le
talon d'Achille du tourisme débutant
quoi
quand tu voyages pour la première fois
même les bidonvilles de Calcutta tu
trouves ça exotique
et si en plus tu as la chance d'être
traversé par la tourista tu frôles la
transmissible
[Applaudissements]
international toujours cette affaire
d'écoute aux États-Unis alors il parait
que c'est un programme qui détecte les
messages avec les mots clés bombe et
attentats
prennent vraiment les terroristes pour
des cons quand même
mais ce qui est vraiment inquiétant
c'est que il paraît qu'on a un centre de
surveillance en France aussi
si ostéate ils sont aussi nuls j'ose pas
imaginer le niveau chez nous et le
logiciel chez nous il doit tiquer sur
des mots comme incivilité au grand frère
international a toujours bientôt des
élections en Iran alors comme dans
toutes les grandes démocraties
il y a deux camps il y a les
conservateurs et les progressistes alors
voilà la modernité le mec de gauche
on est rassuré ainsi dans deux ans ils
ont pas le mariage pour tous ça va c'est
Grèce fermeture de la télévision
publique je suis très inquiet du coup il
y a plus de il y a plus de solutions de
secours pour Aliagas quoi c'est
qu'est-ce qui fait si
pauvre grec la télé grecque c'est quand
même la double peine les gens ils ont
plus de boulot ils sont chez eux ils ont
plus de télé
tu sais
ils vont être obligés de lire comme quoi
la seule vraie politique culturelle
c'est l'austérité
balance commerciale enfin une lueur
d'espoir dans les échanges entre la
France et le monde oui on a retrouvé un
Vélib' à Bamako
c'est véridique
Trocadéro suite aux émeutes 11 nouvelles
arrestations alors 11 moi je veux bien
que la police fasse du zèle mais de là à
coffret l'équipe du PSG
[Musique]
médecine le premier greffé des deux
jambes a été amputé
à cela enfin ajouter ou Arthur
argent géant a touché 10000 euros de
prime par mois c'est pas cher payé quoi
le mec il doit travailler 24 heures par
jour avec des flics
toi bouffer tous les jours à la cantine
avec Derrick et Navarro
bon transition avec un peu d'amour ça
DSK a été approché par les autorités du
Sud Soudan DSK revient en Afrique
qu'est-ce qui ferait pas pour
reconquérir Nafissatou
[Applaudissements]
allez bonne nouvelle
musique guitariste du groupe Queen lutte
pour la sauvegarde de 5000 blaireaux en
Angleterre
ça peut sembler pathétique mais quand on
pense que le guitariste de Johnny lui
doit jouer devant eux
ah ouais non moi Johnny pas de pitié
pour les fans de Johnny coton Johnny
Hallyday qui a déclaré j'ai refusé les
Beatles
dans une carrière refuser les Beatles
c'est dire oui à Zazie si c'est pas du
flair
c'est un peu comme si tu vois arriver
Steve Jobs dans ton bureau avec un
prototype d'iPhone et tu lui dis non non
ce qui va marcher c'est le fourneau
chanson toujours il y a deux bonnes
femmes actuellement qui se battent pour
l'héritage d'un défunt bon après la
fouine et Booba Jennifer et France
je sens que ça va se finir à coup de
Louboutin dans une vente privée Sephora
la musique c'est compliqué c'est un art
très compliqué très quand on a des
cordes vocales on chante quand on a une
plume on écrit quand on a à l'oreille on
compose et quand on a rien de tout ça
bah on fait du rap enfin c'est
[Applaudissements]
à propos de musique exotique
il y a eu les yabons à wards à Paris oui
ça c'est le ciel et César qui récompense
des personnalités pour des phrases
racistes donc le truc plutôt sympa
familial quoi le truc bon en revanche
c'est toujours les mêmes quoi les
lauréats Copé Elizabeth Lévy Véronique
Genest qu'est-ce qu'ils ont de plus que
moi
terminons sur une bonne nouvelle Michael
Youn a encore été cambriolé avec un peu
de chance pour le cinéma les voleurs
auront aussi dérobé les scénarios des
prochains films alors
[Applaudissements]
politique élection à Villeneuve-sur-Lot
et cette très bonne nouvelle le PS reste
quand même troisième partie de France
non ils sont devant les verres et
Mélenchon c'est
en même temps de l'autre côté François
Fillon dans les Alpes-Maritimes il cite
les grandes inventions françaises le
soutif et le béton
c'est que des trucs qui empêchent de
bouger
Fillon à la tête de l'État son plan de
réforme ça va s'appeler le Livre blanc
de la camisole
international c'était le G8 cette
semaine c'est intéressant j'ai 8 c'était
cet endroit où des technocrates sans
cravate viennent se faire humilier par
un Russe sans scrupule
en gros le G8 c'est un peu c'est un
bacrum sm tenu par un cosaque donc
démocratie toujours
en Iran le progressiste a gagné ça va
faire bouger les choses on pendra
toujours les homosexuels mais avec une
corde rose
baccalauréat
le bac coûte 1,5 milliards d'euros quel
gâchis ça coûte cher à former des
chômeurs à ce prix là c'est vraiment
alors j'ai regardé les sujets du bac en
histoire un sujet très intéressant la
France est un État qui conserve
aujourd'hui une certaine influence à
l'échelle du monde justifier cette
affirmation en donnant deux arguments
bah lol et mdr
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est pas très grave les profs ont été
invités à surnommer à l'épreuve de
français ça c'est une bonne idée faire
croire des débiles qu'ils ont compris
Rousseau alors qu'ils sont incapables de
résumer Marc Levy
[Applaudissements]
un texte de Jean-Jacques Goldman a été
proposé au bac en français ça aurait été
pour l'épreuve de musique j'aurais été
plus surpris quoi
la discipline reine reste la philo avec
ce truc le travail permet-il de prendre
conscience de soi ah non il y a qu'à
voir Zahia elle a déclaré que son métier
c'était courtisane et non pas prostitué
la différence entre une prostituée et
une courtisane selon Wikipédia c'est
qu'elles sont plus les traits et elle
vivait avec des écrivains des artistes
des aristocrates ah oui c'est vrai que
quand tu vois le sa clientèle c'est pile
dans la définition
[Applaudissements]
Ribéry Benzema la première chose qui
devient à l'esprit c'est l'arbre
généalogique des Bourbons Rodin Victor
Hugo c'est le truc
Zahia dont les confidences télévisuelles
ont fait plus d'audience que
l'intervention de Hollande dans Capital
mais ça s'explique enfin les Français
préfèrent la pratique à la théorie entre
un type qui dissertent sur le chômage
des jeunes et une qui a trouvé la
solution pour en sortir
non mais Hollande dans un magazine de M6
tu vas avoir été sur TF1 M6 la suite
c'est quoi on dirait le parcours d'un
candidat déçu de la téléréalité la
prochaine étape ça va être les
Corréziens à Mykonos
[Applaudissements]
scolarité toujours un prof a commis des
attouchements hors cadre scolaire alors
on la cable mais je trouve que c'est
assez sain quoi on sait bien nos hobby
job
qui tâche enfin musique j'ai été un peu
dur avec Johnny la dernière fois j'ai
dit que son guitariste devait jouer
devant 5000 blaireaux je retire ce que
j'ai dit ils étaient beaucoup plus
nombreux
à Johnny
des costumes à paillettes il fait
l'amour à un micro il se déhanche à ce
rythme là dans 10 ans il fait du rock
quoi
amour
pourquoi je me balance je pense qu'on a
retrouvé l'auteur de La Princesse de
Clèves ah ouais ça doit être Christine
Lagarde
qui a aussi du signé Les Liaisons
dangereuses puisque c'est le Monde
publie une lettre un peu olé olé très
c'est le bon le monde qui invente la
paparazzade de la pièce à conviction peu
importe bref comme tout le monde j'ai
été choqué par cette lettre tu es
utilise moi guide-moi c'est très
bourgeois aucune fantaisie de la part
d'une directrice du FMI moi je pensais
trouver des à langage un peu plus fleuri
comme je sais pas moi viens injecte de
la liquidité dans mon déficit intérieur
relance la compétitivité de mais au
fourneaux
baisse les charges sociales dans la
culotte
justice
de décision formidables alors les
agresseurs du RER D ont eu des peines de
prison avec sursis alors que le militant
anti-mariage gay vient d'être condamné à
deux mois de prison ferme
c'est génial la justice française c'est
super pédagogue d'un côté on empêche
ceux qui dépouillent de mieux se former
en prison et d'un autre côté on permet à
ceux qui refusent les rapports au mot
d'aller approfondir le sujet
[Applaudissements]
formidable travail
fait divers bon ça c'est une en
Nouvelle-Zélande il y a une femme de 36
ans qui s'est fait engrosser par un
gosse de 11 ans
là-bas à 11 ans déjà c'est des hommes
maintenant tu comprends pourquoi avec
une précocité pareille mettre 30 à 0 à
l'équipe de France de rugby
[Applaudissements]
en Australie toujours le sud une
australienne qui parle avec un accent
français après un accident de voiture
c'est un cas bizarre mais bon les
scientifiques se pencheraient maintenant
sur un cas encore plus rare un Français
qui parler anglais sans accent
[Applaudissements]
bonne nouvelle ah terminons alors on a
des nouvelles Depardieu il veut une
nationalité supplémentaire je sais pas
quoi j'imagine que c'est dans le cadre
d'un plan défiscalisation parce qu'à
force de cumuler les endroits de séjour
il va bientôt payer ses impôts à l'ONU
alors pas belle la vie
comme bac cette semaine a commencé par
une polémique comme seul ce joli pays
c'est en produire Cahuzac à l'Assemblée
nationale dsko Sénas je vois pas ce
qu'il y a de choquant ça fait un an
qu'on a héros à Matignon donc
politique toujours la menace brune a été
écartée de Villeneuve-sur-Lot c'est vrai
que c'est une menace terrible c'est vrai
moi j'ai entendu parler le gars du FN la
Bousquet Cassagne
mon épicier chinois a plus d'éloquence
alors qu'il parle pas français
en tout cas si durant les municipales de
2014 il y aura ce fameux raz-de-marée du
FN qu'on annonce un ça risque de sentir
assez vite la moule et le bulot dans les
mairies
politique et morale Bernard Tapie il est
fort c'est mon héros quoi ce mec c'est
vraiment c'est le seul type qui est
capable d'arriver en garde à vue et de
se débrouiller pour qu'on inculpe aussi
son avocat
[Applaudissements]
toujours avec un avocat de secours on
sait jamais c'est un habitué à ce stade
tapis il doit avoir un double des clés
de sa cellule c'est
c'est vraiment un gâchis vu ses
affinités avec la justice au lieu de
perdre son temps à lancer des journaux
ferait mieux de racheter Fresnes ou les
Baumettes et puis de
c'est vrai quand on regarde sa carrière
d'entrepreneur la seule boîte qui refait
tourner c'est le parquet
politique toujours
Montebourg déclare que Barroso est le
carburant du FN et un peu en retard
monbourg ça fait longtemps que le FN
carburant à l'arabe et au rhum plutôt
qu'au portugais
je crois je sais pas
c'est étonnant cette situation à
portugais ultralibéral patron de
l'Europe à quand un taliban membre des
Femen
justice selon un ex détenu dans les
prisons chinoises les prisonniers font
des écouteurs pour des compagnies
aériennes
70 heures par semaine payer un euro j'ai
essayé de faire le calcul horaire mon
ordinateur a planté trois fois
alors évidemment on a forcément ça a
donné des idées on a essayé la même
chose dans les prisons françaises ça a
pas marché les matos n'étaient pas assez
travailleur
sport à faire Jalabert c'est terrible ce
qui arrive est-ce vraiment nécessaire
d'accabler un type dont le palmarès
prouve que le dopage de marche pas
[Applaudissements]
non mais il a gagné quatre étapes du
tour dans sa vie quand on a dû lui
injecter un placebo c'est pas possible
alors moi j'ai vu son témoignage alors
c'est les aveux à la Jalabert quoi en
terme de défense virant qu'à côté c'est
maître Vergès c'était vraiment le type
ouais bon j'arrivais dans la roulotte on
me faisait des soins des soins et le
type il rentre dans la caravane il
montre un genou écorché on va dire non
non on va pas prendre de risques qu'on
va faire deux piqûres une transfusion
comme ça sera bien désinfecté tu sais
t'inquiète pas déjà la bière ça doit
être le seul mec qui fait un séjour en
thalasso et qui s'étonne qui est pas de
machine à dialyse tu vois
d'ailleurs cette année on nous promet
pas de dopage pas de dopage de toute
façon il y a pas besoin qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce que le Tour de France c'est
quoi 3400 km 21 étapes de jours de repos
six étapes de montagne une moyenne de 40
km/h en général tu prends deux gouttes
d'huile essentielle le matin c'est bon
alors
sport toujours Laurent Blanc nommé au
PSG bah c'est normal c'est la période du
repêchage au bac
le choix de Laurent Blanc c'est vraiment
comment dire tu sais quand tu es
dimanche ton frigo est vide puis tu
arrives lundi matin au supermarché les
rayons sont pas encore remplis et tu as
qu'une boîte de cassoulet Leader Price
qui est encore là tu vois et tu dis bah
face à m'a fait penser à Laurent Blanc
fonction publique
Léna veut changer le profil des élèves
qu'elle recrute alors maintenant l'école
désire des candidats avec de la
personnalité et des exemples de
transparence la personnalité et de la
transparence enfin ça va donner des Mick
Jagger en plexiglas
[Applaudissements]
je sais pas
taxi parisien Samy Naceri
a brisé une vitre bah on postule comme
on peut chez Carglass chacun
alors l'affaire bon il y a une rixe
devant une boîte de nuit et résultat il
a eu une interruption temporaire de
travail de huit jours
bon travail toujours
je veux pas critiquer taxi pas pas
insulter le cinéma enfin taxi c'est
quand même le seul film au monde qui
essaye de te faire croire qu'on peut
doubler une Porsche avec une Peugeot
quoi c'est
affaire Méric l'enquête avance alors
apparemment il aurait sauté dans le dos
du skinhead prendre un mec de dos et
décédé à part quand une capote pète
attention je vois que ça crée un malaise
c'est c'est une mort un peu à la con
c'est vrai que le jeune il avait de
l'avenir je veux dire j'ose pas avant de
devenir un mec sérieux il était trop de
ski donc si on avait laissé la paix à
Clément peut-être qu'en 2017 il
soutenait à NKM je sais pas dans la
foulée les jnrs ont été dissoutes bah
oui c'est Serge Ayoub a convoqué ces
quatre potes et leur a dit bon il faut
qu'on arrête de se voir là
on est trop visible à notre mouvement ça
commence à c'est très émouvant surtout
lors du vote à main levée c'était
bon coin une famille Rome a vendu son
gamin 15000 euros
il a été rendu il a été rendu belle
opération avec les portefeuilles ramenés
la famille a fait une plus-value de 5000
euros
mariage gay on va finir on peut douceur
un maire refuse de marier des gays je
vois pas pourquoi on le critique c'est
quand même vachement gentil de sa part
de pas vouloir gâcher la fête
Robert est-ce que vous voulez vraiment
prendre pour époux Sylvia s'il vient
c'est ça excuse-moi je peux vous appeler
Sylvie parce que sinon on va pas
[Applaudissements]
maintenant vous pouvez vous serrez vous
je vais mettre de dos non de biais parce
que sinon j'ai peur
enfin je trouve que c'est vraiment un
axe citoyen de passer les brèves quand
on en a pas les moyens je pense que
c'est vachement engagé que je dis j'ai
l'impression d'être Sofia bonne nouvelle
il y en a-t-il une oui Hollande rend
hommage à aimer ses airs qui salue une
figure intimement liée à l'esprit de la
République bon oui oui en même temps moi
j'ai écouté la Compagnie Créole ce
weekend j'en ai pas fait tout un plat
alors
bonjour
nous sommes le 6 juillet je suis à bout
là j'en peux plus ça fait un an que je
me nourris de Hollande héros du flow
Najat Vallot quoi j'ai l'impression
d'être un carnivore enfermé dans un bac
à légumes ça c'est
alors nouvelle principale de la semaine
les États-Unis nous les espionne waouh
la nouvelle du siècle si le premier
squelette humain a été retrouvé en
Afrique on est sûr que c'est en France
qu'on va déterrer le premier squelette
de bisounours
ici on n'y croyait pas c'est énorme mais
pourtant Obama quand il nous dit bonjour
il sourit donc il peut pas
humiliation suprême l'Allemagne est 7
fois plus espionné que la France ça
c'est normal c'est normal pas très bien
ce qu'on peut pomper sur la France c'est
les 35 heures sudrive je sais pas je
pense que les USA quand il nous
espionnent c'est pour se détendre quand
ils écoutent l'Allemagne ils ont
l'impression d'être sur France Info dès
qu'il passe sur la France et rires et
chansons c'est
[Applaudissements]
politique toujours alors Hollande a
réagi avec autorité il a viré Delphine
bateau l'espionne descendu du néolienne
la Mata Hari du compost tout cas
François il a le sens du timing les
Français partent en vacances tout le
monde s'en fout de la politique et la
Raoul qui décide de montrer qu'il en a
dans quel but quand il est là comme ça
là puis virer bateau pour l'exemple le
gouvernement ressemble à un nid de
moustique et lui il bute la coccinelle
m'a vachement sensibilisé au
parce qu'en fait chez moi il y a il y a
une poubelle verte c'est une poubelle
noire bon il y en a une autre avec un
trou où ça fait scling de enfin jamais
compris à quoi ça servait ça doit être
un peu de chant pour les gens avec les
pieds un peu longs tout ça je sais pas
très bien et jusque là je pensais qu'on
pouvait mettre que des trucs verts dans
la poubelle verte
mais en fait mais en fait non parce que
Delphine bateau elle a ma sensibilisé
quoi
alors elle a été remplacée par Philippe
Martin ouais c'est un type très
c'est qui en fait
[Applaudissements]
tout le monde se palluge sur à
l'écologie c'est important quoi c'est il
faut il y a jamais une grosse pointure
pour gérer le ministère de l'écologie
jamais Mister l'écologie ça me fait
penser à la bonne copine tu vois tout le
monde t'explique que c'est la famille
idéale mais personne veut la tirer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bref et
alors apparemment maintenant le
printemps arabe c'est une fois par an
bah ça se comprend quand on sait qu'il y
a eu à peu près 100 agressions sexuelles
en quelques jours place tarir pourquoi
arrêter de manifester quoi c'est en fait
la place tarière c'est devenu un club
échangiste en plein air c'est
plus une révolution démocratique c'est
sexuelle c'est jouir sans entrave sous
le ni câble à tout enfin c'est très
alors résultat elle est manifestants ont
été entendus c'est-à-dire que l'armée a
dégagé le président morcy président qui
était à 32% d'opinion positives tu vois
c'est à ce genre de détails qu'on
remarque que l'armée française est
complètement sclérosée
[Applaudissements]
Front national Marine a perdu son
immunité parce que elle a parlé
d'occupation pour désigner des prières
de rue dans les prières de russe c'est
vrai que c'est un sujet qui excite les
gens quoi c'est moi j'ai un copain homo
qui a un appart juste au-dessus de la
rue en question tu as été ravi quoi à
chaque fois qu'il y avait une prière de
rue il allait jamais à la terrasse sans
son rouleau de sopalin
[Applaudissements]
morale
Bernard Tapie est sorti de sa garde à
vue boum direct le 20h de gîte de France
2 enfin agité après un juge c'est comme
du stretching après un match de boxe
avec Pujadas dans le rôle du jacuzzi
puisada s'il est mignon il a beau
barboté il est encore quand même
alors le pauvre qui a essayé d'arracher
des aveux à Bernard Tapie tout en finale
Bernard Tapie vous avez été mis en
examen dans cette affaire d'escroquerie
en bande organisée est-ce que cet
arbitrage a été une escroquerie
le type il croit qu'en 3 minutes il va
lui arracher l'aveu que les trois juges
qui l'ont mis sous séquestre ont pas
réussi à avoir
[Applaudissements]
tapis les magistrats moi la fin de
l'intervention je me suis dit vraiment
le pauvre quoi il a eu que 45 millions
de dommages d'intérêt Crédit Lyonnais
c'est vraiment des [ __ ]
divertissement de qualité quoi c'est
Nabilla avec un QI moi je
mercato télé on en parle en ce moment
télé sur plateau profitons-en alors en
sortant des studios de TF1 clair Chazal
s'est ramassé un saut d'excrément à
travers la vitre de sa voiture elle a
réagi avec classe la regarder
[Applaudissements]
sport l'exf footballeur Basile Boli est
condamné à deux ans de prison avec
sursis pour abus de confiance quand on
sait qu'il a joué à l'OM sous l'air
tapis prendre du sursis c'est un hommage
au patron
santé le stress multiplie par deux le
risque cardiovasculaire c'est toujours
moins que la détente qui multiplie par 5
le risque de travailler dans la fonction
publique
alors bonne nouvelle de la semaine les
talibans ouvre un bureau au Qatar
bah oui forcément lourde ou Versailles
c'était un peu tangent c'est l'objectif
avouer c'est s'ouvrir au monde et
inviter les gens à mieux connaître les
talibans leur culture leur joie de vivre
c'est être taliban est tenté de séduire
à l'international c'est comme vouloir
choper sur adopte un mec en mettant pour
photo de profil la liste de TMST c'est
vraiment le truc alors pas belle la vie
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu